In this course, you will learn how to automate
a bunch of different things in Python. You will
learn about web scraping, automating downloads,
extracting from PDFs, automated image processing,
building an automated new summarizer and more.
The instructor for this course is Abdul, also
known as one little coder. He has been creating
courses for a while and is a great teacher.
Welcome to the section one of hands on with tools
to automate stuff in Python. In this section,
we'll build Hacker News Headlines, emailer will
begin with the understanding of the basics of web
scraping. Then we'll set up a system environment
by installing the required Python packages.
Then we'll move on to understand the project
architecture. And then we'll start scraping
project with Hacker News front page. And then
finally, we'll complete the email section
to finish the tool building so the tool
can send us the Hacker News Headlines.
In this video, we'll learn about project
architecture of building an automated Hacker
News Headlines email. This architecture starts
with getting the content of the Hacker News
website front page, so we'll use the Python
package request to get the get request
to extract the content of the website. Once
we have the content of the website in place,
we'll use a Python package beautifulsoup to scrape
the recorded content. So the required content,
I mean, the components like title, link, score,
domain name, etc. So we'll use beautifulsoup. To
extract these required components from the content
that we had extracted from the previous step.
The next step is to build the email body or the
content of the email. From the scraped content.
We'll arrange it in such a way that the email
body looks like there is a title there is a link,
there is a number so that the email body looks
exactly like a news presentation. And once we
have the email body ready, we'll move on to the
email authentication section, where we will use
your Gmail ID. to authenticate the email section,
we'll use the Python package SMTP lib to set up
an SMTP library authentication system where we'll
use a gmail authentication once the authentication
is set up. And then we have provided or email id
and then other necessary information. Finally,
we are going to send that email using the email
body that we have set up. So ultimately, what
we are doing is we are extracting content from
the web page. And then we are going to take the
required components and then use the component to
build an email body and then use the email body in
the email that we compose and then we sent it to
the required users. In the next video, we'll start
to learn how to set up our Python environment in
such a way that we have all the required packages.
In this video, we'll learn how to set up
our Python environment in such a way that
we have all the required packages. These are
the following packages that we will be using
in this particular project. Request package
is used for HTTP requests. beautifulsoup is
used for web scraping. SMTP lib is used for
email authentication and email transaction,
email dot mine is used for creating the email
body. And then finally date time is used for
accessing or manipulating date and time. But these
packages SMTP lib email dot mine on day 10 comes
by default with your Python installation. So what
we have to do is there are two external libraries
request package and beautifulsoup that we are
supposed to install in our Python environment.
So let us go ahead and see how to install
those two packages that are required. First,
open your terminal and then make sure that you
have Python installed already. Once you have
Python installed already, you can start with
PIP three install requests. Once you enter it,
Python is going to look up for requests and then
it is going to get a request package from pi pi
which is the repository where all the packages
are available and then it is going to install in
your machine. To check if request packages
installed. Let us invoke our Python three
console and then check input requests. As you
can see it has successfully imported so let us
exit and now move ahead with the next package. The
next package that we are supposed to installers,
Pip three install Beautiful Soup for now again
Beautiful Soup is getting downloaded from pi pi
and then Beautiful Soup is getting installed. So
as we can see Beautiful Soup is installed now, let
us go ahead and invoke our Python three console
and then To check if beautifulsoup is installed
As you can see Beautiful Soup even though is the
package name while you are importing the package
in your Python session, you have to use bs for
as you can see bs four is successfully installed.
You can even check if a particular object is
getting imported bs from VS code input beautiful.
So, as you can see B is capital here and s also
also capital. So it has successfully imported.
So let us exit our Python environment. For now
we have successfully installed beautifulsoup for
and then request package. Both are the
external libraries that are required for
this particular project. And all other packages
like SMTP lib, email, dot mime and date time
are inbuilt present in our Python setup.
But let us make sure that those packages
are available also. So let us invoke our
Python console once again, Python three.
Let us clear our terminal
First, open Python three,
and then do import SMTP lib SMTP
lib is successfully imported.
Let us input email.my email that mine was
successfully imported. Let us input date,
time, date time is also successfully imported. So
this tells us that all the required packages are
available in the Python environment that we have
got. So we are good to go ahead with our project.
In this video, they start to learn how to code
the project script. For this code editing,
I'm using Python Community Edition.
But you can use any ID of your choice.
So make sure that Python installation is proper
in your machine and Python is added in the system
path, then you can use any code editor to do the
same thing that I'm going to show you right now.
We'll start with importing all
the packages that are required.
And if you remember, those are
the packages that we installed.
In the previous section. I will start with import
requests, which is for our HTTP request. And then
we'll import Beautiful Soup from bs for Next,
we'll move on to importing SMTP lib. And then
we'll input two objects from email mime.
And then finally we'll import date time.
Once all the inputs are finished, we'll start
with extracting the current date time, which
is the system date time. The reason we are using
date time to extract the current date time is to
create an email subject line where it will show us
the appropriate date when the email was sent. This
is for us to make sure that the same email get
doesn't get overwritten every day. So that we have
an understanding that every day we are receiving
a new email from the automated email. So the next
step is to create an empty Python object with
nothing, it's a string object with nothing in it,
which is going to be used as an email content
placeholder. Once we are ready with this thing,
we can move on to start creating a new
function where we will extract the Hacker News
components that we are required. First, let us
create a function called extract underscore news,
which will take one argument which is a URL that
it is required to keep the user updated will print
the user message saying extracting Hacker News
stories. Then we'll create another temporary
placeholder, which is again an empty string. So
this temporary placeholder is going to be used to
assign value to this content, which is the actual
email body that we want. So the first line that we
want in our email body is to say that this is a 10
top stories, it N stands for Hacker News. And then
we are going to display a 10 top stories and it
is going to be a bold text. And then we are going
to have line breaks and then we are going to show
star star star star just to make it more readable
once this line is defined. Now we will move on to
get the content of the URL, the URL that we are
going to pass to this function when we call this
function. So we are going to use request packets
get function to get the content of this URL and
then store it in the response object. The content
once we get from the get function is actually in
response body HTTP response, which will contain
content the actual content that is required for
us which is the content of the webpage. So we
are going to use the method content on the object
response to store the actual content in content.
Remember, this is a global object which is
called And this is a local object within this
particular function, which means these two are
different. So the scope of this particular content
lies only within this function. So do not get
confused with this content and this content.
Now, we are going to use this content that we
extracted using the response body. And we are
going to use the HTML parser to extract or make
a soup out of it. from that particular soup,
what we are going to be interested is about the
components that we are going to require in this
particular project. So, to understand what are
the components that we are going to required,
we have to see the website structure. So, in the
next video, we will see the website structure of
the Hacker News front page to see what are
the components that we would be required
to extract using this beautifulsoup function?
In this video, we'll see what are the components
that we need from the Hacker News front page
website. And as you can see from this code,
this is the URL that we are going to use. And
this is the Hacker News front page URL. So let
us go to our browser. So in this case, I'm using
Mozilla Firefox. So let us go to our browser,
and then open Hacker News front page. And this
is how the site actually looks. This is one of
the most popular websites on the internet. And
this was started by Paul Graham was a very famous
personality, and internet entrepreneur. And he
also runs an incubator called Y Combinator. So
this is a website that has been read by 1000s
and 1000s of people every day. And our objective
is to extract this content and automatically send
an email to us so that we can see why only when
there is an important or interesting content
for us to see, then we can go to the website,
that is the objective of this entire project.
So as we can see, this website, we can see
a header in this website or a navigation bar.
And then we have list, which is very similar to
how, you know Reddit kind of website look. So
in this setup, there are some components that
we could be interested in to understand what is
the link? Or what is the information about First,
we need this one, which is the actual title
of the link, then we would be also interested
in knowing the points which shows how popular
that particular link is. So to know what are
the contents that we should be escaping from this
website, we have to first open our web inspector.
To open web Inspector, you can
either press F 12 in your keyboard,
or you can right click in your machine, the
browser using your mouse and then click inspect
element. So click Inspect Element, then you will
get this particular page opened, which will give
you a sense of how the web page is designed
to let us slightly increase the size of this.
And let us pick the pick an element tool. So now
we have picked up this tool to understand what are
the components that we need from this particular
Hacker News front page, which we will use in the
code to extract that particular component from the
content that we have already extracted. So pick
this thing and then go here, as you can see this,
as you hover, you can actually see the CSS value,
which is also called the selector. As you can see,
moreover, you can see a dot story link here you
can see a dot h and user a dot some score value,
then you can actually see a then you can see a
so what we can see is we can click mouse and then
see how we don't have to actually click we can
just hover around and we can actually see how the
chord changes and then the first area of interest
for us was the title. So who are your most of them
and click the button. As you can see, once you
hover there what you actually get is you get an A
anchor text with the class story link and which is
present inside a table with class title. So,
the first point that we are looking for is
anchor text with story link. So let us go to our
code and see what we have written. So what is our
area of interest is we are trying to extract
everywhere where we have got db, db is in HTML
is the actual sale inside a table HTML table HTML
table is created using this tag table. A table row
is created using this tag BR and then the values
the actual sales inside the table row is using
created using the tag the D in this step what
we are trying to do is we are trying to tell
beautiful su to find all TD from this particular
soup that we have just created. de su. So, we are
using the function find all to find everything
that is TD, but as you can see, we are trying
to find everywhere where there is TD with class
title. So, as you can see, we are trying to find
everywhere there there is class title and then
we are trying to extract the components of it
everywhere there is class title and then
we are trying to extract the components
or the values inside it that is exactly
what we're doing in this function
soup dot find all DD and then the attributes
the HTML attributes that we are looking for this
class title and then we align we align
is something that you can actually see,
this is what we are trying to find out from this
particular webpage. So, we are trying to find
everything that is TD and we are trying to
extract that using this attribute class title
and then we are saying we align should be empty
the first attribute class should have value title,
the second attribute we align should have
nothing in it. So, just let us see it once again.
Once you click the inspector tool, and then
however on the page, you click on the title
that you want, and you can actually see the
title The TD plus attribute holds the value title
and then the we align like this one is not present
yet. So, this is to eliminate the junk and then
extract the component that we want. So, once we do
that, we are trying to find wherever we are trying
to convert the entire thing as a text. So, to see
that we have to understand one more thing, what
we are actually seeing is this is okay. So, we are
extracting TD, which has class title, but that is
only for the first element, but what we need is
we need all the links, we need all the 30 links
from this particular page for us to to do that, we
are trying to put this entire thing in a for loop
and then we are using this function enumerate
just for one simple purpose because in the final
email that we want, we want numbers 123456 until
30. So, for that purpose, we are trying to use
enumerate which will give us the actual number the
index value and also the value of this output. So
we are using a for loop and we are using a
numerate to say okay, I want all the values
that is output of this thing, which will give
us all the text all the scraped output and
then we are saying enumerated so that we have
the index value and we also have the actual
tag that is extracted from this page. And once
we do that, we are entering into the for loop
trying to build the email content actual content.
So as we just discussed, we are trying to
create the table row number with this value I and
as you can see, Python is a zero index language.
So what we are trying to do is we are trying
to say okay, I plus one which will give us
one for the first row and then two three
until 30 so on and then we are going to
we are trying to actually have a nice looking
format just like this, which will separate the
index number from the actual title and then we are
trying to convert everything. What we are trying
to do is we are trying to convert everything that
we just extracted using dot txt into a text. So we
are trying to say okay, you have given me the
tag, but I don't want the entire day, I just
want that text inside the tag. So the value inside
the tag. So we are using tag dot txt to do that.
And then now we need a line break. So we are going
to use br which is an HTML tag for the line break.
And then one more thing is required here, which
is if you can notice in this particular page,
you have got all the title letters again open our
whip inspector and you have got all the title. But
at the end of the page, you actually have another
title which is TD class title, we aligned nothing,
but this value is more. So in order to avoid this
more getting captured in our final output email
body, we are trying to eliminate this saying
that we want everything one to 30 except when
there is a value more that is what exactly we
are doing. We are saying we want everything
except when the tag is not equal to more. We
are saying give me everything when the tag is
not equal to more. And then we are concatenating
it for every row. So this for loop is executing
for every row and then every row value is getting
added in the CNT. And at the end of this function,
we are returning this object Python object that
we created, which was an empty placeholder string,
as CMT. To recap, this particular
function, this function is to extract
the front page links or title or the components
that we wanted So we are creating a function
called extract underscore news, where we are
passing on the URL. And then we are creating a
nice title, which says agent top stories,
and then we are extracting the content,
we are using beautifulsoup to extract make a soup
out of it. And then we are using soup dot find all
to find all the teeny tags with attributes class
title, and then we align nothing. And then we are
trying to create rows using this thing. And while
we are creating rows, we also noticed that there
is one final row which has a value more which we
do not want. So we are excluding that. And then
finally we are returning the entire object, TNT as
the result of this function. In the next section,
we'll see how to call the function, and
then we'll move on to composing the email.
In the previous video, we learned how
to build a custom function that we use
for extracting the news from Hacker News friend
page. In this video, we'll see how to call it
function, how to finish the email content, and
then how to start with email authentication.
So to start with, we can see the function that we
tried to build in the previous section is called
extract underscore news. That takes one argument
which is a URL to invoke the function or to call
the function, we are going to say extract
underscore news. And then we are going to
pass on the URL of that Hacker News friend
page as a string, once we do this thing,
this function gets executed and then whatever
is returned in C and D will get assigned to this
particular CNT. And as we saw in the previous
section, this C and T is a local object whose
scope is within this function. And this C and
T is part of a global object, which has scope
in the entire code. Once we have this end, what we
are going to do is we are going to append this end
to the content placeholder that we created. So we
are saying just content plus equal to which is as
equal and as content is equal to content plus. So
instead of this thing, we are going to simply say
content CNT plus equal to c NT at the end of
the email body, then we are trying to put empty
lines with dashes to denote that the email is
finished. And then finally, we are going to
add two more lines and then say this is the
end of the message. This is just for us to
make the email more professional, more useful in
understanding where the email starts with this
thing and where the email actually ends. Once we
have this finished, what we are going to now do
is we are going to start with the email composing
state. And then the first step of email composing
is to create the parameters that is required for
email authentication, as we saw in the project
architecture section, so once the email
composition, the email body is ready, we
are going to start with the email authentication.
For email authentication, there are five important
parameters that we have to define first, what
is the email server, the SMTP server that you
are going to use? Second, what is the port
number? Third, what is the from address email
address where you want to send the email? What
is the address where you want to send the email,
and then finally, the password of the address from
address from where you want to send that email.
One thing that you have to keep in mind is this
to address could be actually a list where you
want to send this email to multiple recipients.
So in this particular project, we will see how to
send this email to yourself so that you can keep
yourself updated with Hacker News Headlines every
day. But actually, you can even send this email
to multiple person provided that you give a list
of email ids list. When I mean list, it's actually
a Python list. So to start with, we are going to
use a Gmail account for this particular step. So
we are going to stay SMTP gmail.com, which is the
SMTP email server for Gmail. And for Gmail, the
port number is 587. And then the next thing is
the from email ID, which should be in character
as a string. So for the sake of this particular
project, I'm going to use my gmail account from
where I want to send my email. And then also,
this is the same email ID for which I want to send
this email to remember, the to address could be
a list of email ids, where we have multiple email
ids so that this one email could be sent to a lot
of people. And then finally we have the password
that we are going to use for this email account.
So you enter the password that is required to log
into this account. And then this will complete the
parameters that we wanted. Once we have this in
place. The next thing is we are going to create
the message body. So the message body that we want
is a mime multipart. So we are creating an empty
object with using function mind multipad. And
then we have to add the subsequent components
of an email, an email is supposed to have an
important thing, which is called an email subject.
So to create an email subject, there are multiple
things that we can actually do. The first nyovest
thing that we can actually do is we can have a
title, that doesn't change. But the disadvantage
with that is, in an email client, like Gmail,
or outlook, if you have the same title, every
email that comes next day gets folded in the same
conversation, instead of having a different email,
the same email will be there, and then subsequent
emails will be added as a conversation. So to
avoid that, and also for us to understand when did
we see that particular email, what we are going
to do is, we are going to create a dynamic email
subject and the way we are going to do that is, as
you can remember from the previous videos, we had
created a new object Python object that called now
from the date time package, which will return the
system date the current date. So what we are doing
here is we are saying okay, this is my emails,
which says top news stories, hm automated email,
that's well and good. Next what we are trying to
do is we are trying to actually create the date
object, str now dot they will give you the day.
The next one is str node month. The next one is
str node here. So what we are trying to do is we
are actually trying to create an email subject
line that has the date, component, date, day, and
then your year. So once we have this thing, we are
going to assign it in this mime multipart that we
created as subject. The next is the from address
from the next store address as to and once we
are done with this thing, we are going to attach
the email body the email body that we created
as message MSG dot attach. As you can notice,
here, we are trying to make this an HTML email. If
you remember, we had used Be bold as HTML tags to
make our email look slightly more better than a
normal text email. And that is why we are using
mime text should be content HTML, and then we are
attaching that content to the email. So with this,
our email body is currently ready. Now we are
moving on to the authentication section we are we
are printing the message that initializing server.
Once we have the server components in place,
the next step that we are going to do is we're
going to call SMTP function from the SMTP lib
package. And then we are saying okay, this is my
server, this is my port, I'm going to send it to
server and then this function set underscore
debug level. One is to say whether we want
to see debug messages if the server has issue
in connecting if the server has any problem.
If the authentication is not successful, do you
want to see the error messages or not. So if you
do not want to see the error messages, you can set
zero. If you want to see the error messages, you
can set one which will help you in debugging. Once
we have that thing, we are going to initiate this
over with Hello. And then we are going to start a
TLS connection which is a secured connection. And
then once that is done, we are going to log in
from ID using the password that we have given.
Once the login is successful, then finally we
are going to send the email that we have composed
from this ID to this ID where the message that
we have created is sent as a string using the
function as underscore string. Once the message
is sent successfully, we are going to print a user
message email sent. And then finally, we are going
to quit from the server that we just initialized.
So we are going to initialize the server using the
server and port detail that we just created. We
are going to set the debug level one to understand
the error messages, we are going to initiate the
transaction with the server starting with ello
and then starting with TLS server and then we
are going to log into the from and the ID email
id and then using the password. And then finally
we are going to send the email from this ID to
this ID or set of IDs that we have created here.
And then finally, we are going to send it as a
message using this as underscore string function.
And then finally we are printing a user message
and then we are going to quit from the server.
In the next video we'll see how the email actually
looks and then how do we execute the script. In
the previous section, we completed the actual code
that was required for this particular project.
But before we move on to executing the code, there
is one change that you have to do if you are going
to use your Gmail account. If you are going to
use your custom SMTP like your company email id,
or you're going to have your own email server you
probably would not need to know this thing. But if
you are going to use your Gmail account to send
an automated email, this is one mandatory step
that you have to do otherwise, your email would
draw authentication error. So what is that thing.
So what you have to do is you have to go to
your email account. So what you have to do is
you have to go to my account.google.com slash
security. So this is what you have to open,
security and then you could do Security tab.
Once you get into the Security tab, you will
see something called less secure access,
you'll see less secure app access onto your
scrawled on the top page looks like this.
So once you go at the end, you will see
less secure app access to click this button.
Right now I have it on but for you It should be
ideally off. So what you have to do is you have
to turn it on. So read this message carefully
wants to Google is trying to tell you that you
are trying to enable your email sign in for less
secure technology. And this project that we are
doing it is calling it as less secure technology
because it doesn't use two factor authentication,
unlike your mobile phone or
mobile app or something else.
So Google is trying to let you
know that you are trying to access
or give access to your Gmail login for less secure
app. And this is how exactly the message is for
all the email automation project that you will do.
So that is completely fine. But make sure if you
have two factor authentication, this is not going
to work properly, you have to find another way,
which you can find on Google forums. But for
normal login, if you have a normal login,
this is what you have to do, you have to
go to my account.google.com slash security,
you go click this button. And then by default,
it will be like this for you, which is off.
And then you have to go here and then turn it
on. Once you turn it on, you'll see this message.
And then you will have an ELO
color. Let me refresh the page,
it will take slightly some time for Google to
refresh your on to off logged on to probably
have to wait executing this until that. So now
you can actually see that this is refreshed.
And then it is showing with an exclamatory
Mark, which is lately a warning sign to say
that you have enabled your Gmail login or less
secure apps. Once you are done with this step.
Now you can go ahead and then execute your
code. And then let us open go to the Python
Community Edition that we were using Let us
open the terminal. So please note, you can
even go to your system terminal and then do this
thing. Or even you can use your Python terminal.
For the first time we'll use your Python terminal
to see what are the error messages that we are
getting if you are getting some error messages.
Or if you are not going to get any error messages,
then we can probably you know automate this
entire thing using Windows Task Scheduler,
or a bash script, that would be just simply run
on your terminal or shell. So to start with,
what we have to do is we let us see what
are all the files that we have, these are
the files that we have in this thing. And this
is the particular file that we are of interest,
we will say Python three, and then we are
pasting the file name and then executing it.
As you can see, these are the error messages
or user messages that we were printing.
And now because we had enabled debug level one,
this message has been sent. And you can see that
it is showing that this is first extracting Hacker
News stories composing email initiating server,
all the IP address related details and starting
the TLS server. And then it is saying though,
okay, SMTP has started. And then from this email,
you're sending it to this email. And then this is
your email body starting with automated email.
And then finally you're finishing the email,
and then you're receiving a message that email
sent and then the email connection is closed,
we'll see how to do the same thing using your
terminal. To open the terminal that you have
taught with the terminal that you have like
in my case, I'm going to open my Mac terminal.
And then I'm going to first navigate to
the place where I have got the quotes.
Once you navigate to the folder where you
have got the quotes, now check what are the
files you have got. So these are the files
that we have got. So copy the file name.
Now open Python three, and then filename. You are
executing first extracting the news composing the
email. And it is the same set of messages that
we have seen. So in this video, we learned how to
enable the Google setting that will allow us to
send automated emails through Gmail. And then we
also saw how to execute our script, both in the
Python and also in our terminal. So the way we
execute is using this code, Python three which
is to exit Python three or invoke Python three
console and then the file name. In the next video,
we'll actually see how the email looks like.
In this video, we'll see how the email that we
sent using the previous automated script actually
looks like. Let us go to our email. As you can
see, Google has sent me a critical security alert,
which is just to notify that I had tried to
enable My Account Login for less secure apps.
And you know, that is completely fine for us to
see and then ignore. And then the next thing is,
we can see the email that we sent. As you can
see, you have received two emails, because the
first email was sent using the terminal inside pi
charm. The second email was sent using the shell,
the actual terminal that is in your voice,
which is your command prompt or terminal.
So let us open the email with a slightly zoom
out to see how the email actually looks like.
As you can see, this is the subject of the email
where this is static, what we created. And then
this is the date that is the current system
date. And then you can see a bold email title,
not the subject, actually mail title. And you can
also see that email was sent from to this email.
And you can actually see another important thing
that this email has fallen initiate your inbox
and not inside your spam box. So what happens is,
if you do not have all the email companies that
mime components that we set up, your email might
end up in your spam not in your inbox. So make
sure that you have got all the email components
that we described in the code setup, right? Now
you can see that you have a title, then you have
all the formatting that we did, then you have the
number that we used using the enumerate index i
and then we have this formatting the separator,
and then we have the title. And then finally,
we have the domain name with the link. In fact,
as you can see, we have 30. And then finally, we
have this thing, and then we finally say end of
message. Let us open the next email also, to see
Okay, the first one is this. The second one is
this. And then we have all the 30 items. And then
finally, we are seeing it is in definisi latest
ones, go to the Hacker News site, and then verify
what is it. As you can see, bullshitters is the
first we'll show this is the first out to setup
setting up an ad block, putting up an ad block.
There's no third probably it has changed by the
time we send an email. Now how do I hide from a
surveillance? How do I hide from a surveillance,
this makes sure that the email that we sent
is the actual Hacker News for this time during
the file for 2019. At this time, 25 for 2019.
So in this video, we saw how the actual email
that we sent using the previous script looks like
and in this section, we have learned how to build
an automated Hacker News headline e mailer, which
now further you can extend to probably a Windows
Task Scheduler to send it every day morning,
or using a bash script scheduler or a cron
job to automatically send this email even
without executing. So in the video, start of the
video, the previous section end we learned how
to execute the script. But once you automate
it using a task scheduler or a bash script,
or a cron job, then probably you would not have to
even open or run the script every day, the script
would be automatically executed. There is only one
important thing that you have to keep in your mind
before you know we close this section is that this
email script will contain your email password.
So make sure before you upload it on GitHub or
before you share it with your friends the same
script that you remove your password so that
no one else knows your password. So in this
entire project, what we learned
is, how to scrape a website,
how to extract the components that we want, how to
build an email and how to automatically send that
email from our gmail account. Hope you enjoyed
this section. Let us see in the next section.
In this section, too, we'll learn how to
build a TED talk video downloader, we'll see
how to install requests package and understand
how to use request package for HTTP requests.
With that, we'll build a basic script to download
the video of a given a TED talk. And then we'll
store the video in our local machine. Then we'll
generalize the code to download any TED Talk video
given the URL, and we'll ultimately
package the script as a C light tool.
In this video, we'll see all the packages
that we'll be using in this project.
The first and foremost package that we are going
to use in this project is requests request is a
package that will help us get the web content. And
the request. The name comes from HTTP requests,
which is how the communication between a
server and client happens in a HTTP protocol,
the client sends a request to the server, and
then the server response back since the response
as a result, typical HTTP request contains the
actual request. And then the header lines, like
authentication, and then an optional empty message
body. So sometimes you can have the information
that is required to be passed on in that message
body, the package that we are going to use for
that is requests in Python. So let us see how to
install that required package inside our computer.
So open your terminal. And then as you might have
seen before, because we are using Python three,
we should use PIP three install request. This
will install request package from pi pi. So now
as you can see, a course package is successfully
installed. To verify that we can open our Python
three console, and then import request and then
see that it has been successfully installed.
Thank you for listening, we'll see the next video
about another package, which is Beautiful Soup.
In this video, we'll see about Beautiful Soup.
Beautiful Soup is another important package that
we'll be using in this project. Beautiful Soup
is used to extract data out of HTML and XML,
primarily Beautiful Soup is used for web scraping.
So the request package that we saw in the last
video will give us a content from the webpage. But
as you might have guessed, the content is an HTML
or XML format, in which websites are designed. So
Beautiful Soup is the package that will give us
the formatted content, the extract of whatever we
want from the HTML or XML file that we requested
from the request package as a get request. Let us
see how to install Beautiful Soup package inside
our Python environment. Beautiful so goes by the
name Beautiful Soup for so open your terminal
type PIP three, install and Beautiful Soup for
everything in small case, once you click enter
Beautiful Soup will be collected from pi pi and
then it is going to get successfully installed
in your local machine. To verify whether
beautifulsoup is installed. Let us open
up our Python environment which is Python three,
and then import bs four. As you might have seen,
the package that we installed was beautiful
soup, but when we are going to call it we are
going to use beautiful bs for us Beautiful Soup.
And especially the function that we are going to
use the object that we are going to use from
Beautiful Soup is cumbias for input beautiful.
This is the object that we are going to use from
the package Beautiful Soup. So as you can see,
and you install it, you have to call it
beautifulsoup for when you import it you
have to call bs for and then from that this is a
specific object that we are going to use inside
our code. Let us get into the next video where
we'll see how to build the basic code. Thank you.
In this video, we'll see how to build the first
version of the TED Talk video download it, as
we have seen in the previous videos, we have
successfully installed request package and we have
successfully also install Beautiful Soup package.
So let us start with the code. Let us import the
required packages first in the header section.
And then let us move on to the code. The first
package that we are going to use this request. So
let us import requests. And the second package is
beautiful. So as we saw in the Beautiful Soup
package video, we are going to import Beautiful
Soup the object from the package bs four. And
once we do that, the next package that we will be
requiring is our E which is for regular expression
manipulation. So regular expression, as you might
have known is just to do pattern matching. And
then finally, the package that we're going to use
is Sis, which is for argument parsing, which is to
generalize the code for using multiple URLs as a
combined package. So let us start with the code.
So as we have imported the required packages in
our header section, we'll move on to the further
section. We'll see this exception handling
in the next video. Meanwhile, we'll use a URL that
is hard coded. So here there is a URL of a TED
talk. And that is defined in the object URL. So
the first step is to use request package to send
a get request to get the content of the URL. And
stored in the object. So, because this is going
to be a long process, it is also good to Minter
message to the user who is using this package,
the project that we are developing to
indicate that the download is about to start,
once the request packages successfully get all
the content from the URL of this TED Talk, the
next thing that we are going to do is we are going
to use beautifulsoup. To create a soup out of the
content that we have got. As you can see here,
the response of the get request is stored in our
which is the Python object. But here, when we are
going to use it with beautifulsoup, we are going
to save our content, it is because the response
contains a lot of things like the status code, the
result of the request. So in this entire response
body, the only thing that we are interested
is our dot content, which is the actual content
of the website URL that we extracted. And once
we are going to use beautifulsoup. To assign it
to the soup object, the next step is to identify
the exact location where we have got the mp4.
To understand that let us actually see the
source code of the doc page. When you open an
Tiktok, just like this, when you press Ctrl u,
you will get the actual source of the project.
The page in this page, we have to see where
mp4 is present. So we'll say Control F mp4. As you
can see, this is the place where you have mp4 and
we are interested to extract this particular
URL. But before that, we have to see where
the exact location, this mp4 is present in this
entire page. So we'll just scroll to the first.
And we'll see that this entire content is present
inside a script that starts with top page in it.
And that's exactly what we are going to use
our beautifulsoup code to find within this
entire page. So entire content is present in soup.
And then we are going to say inside soup find
everywhere where you have script. And inside that
script using rejects regular expression we are
going to find for this particular word, and then
we are going to store the result inside result.
And as you can see from this entire script, this
script contains a lot of text. And the only part
that we are interested in is a proper mp4 file.
So we are building a regular expression pattern to
say that it should start with the URL should start
with HTTPS, and then it will contain also mp4. And
then we are going to assign the result in result
underscore mp4. At this point, you might have got
a lot of results. So what we are going to do is
we are going to split everything based on one
separator and then we are going to take the first
output after the split as the proper mp4 URL,
because as you can see, with the mp4, you
actually see medium quality, light quality,
high quality, so not bothering about the quality
of the videos, we are going to just take the first
URL after the split. And then finally we are going
to print a message that we are going to download
video from the URL. And then we have to have a
file name. So to get the file name dynamically,
we are going to use the URL title or the file
name which is also present in here. And then
the final step, we are again going to use GET
request to extract the content of the URL,
which is currently the mp4 file. And then we
are going to use that content to write using
F dot write and then we are going to save in
the output file. So as you might have seen,
this is the mp4 file which should end with dot
mp4, which we extracted from here this part
and then we are going to use F dot write
to write the content of the mp4 file in
the output file that we wanted, which is an mp4
file and then we are going to print a message
that the download process is finished. So in this
video, we learned how to build the entire code,
a generic first version of the code that will
help us in downloading the mp4 video of a TED
x Ted video from ted.com using requests and Bs
for Thank you for listening. In the next video,
we'll see how to generalize this code
so that it can be packaged as a CI tool
that anyone can pass a URL instead of hard coding
it and then download the video. In this video,
we'll see how to generalize the code that we
built using the last video for a better CLA
tool. So what do we mean by UCLA to a CLA tool is
nothing but you can have a package the code that
we develop Have as one line in your terminal,
and then you can get the output of that without
having the need of entering, you know, your PI
charm or without having the need of editing the
code. So as you might have seen in the last video,
we actually hard coded the URL, we gave the URL as
part of the code. But that is not going to help
us in long term because not every time you want
to open a text editor, enter the URL, and then
recompile the entire or execute the entire Python
code. So for that purpose, what we are going to
do is we are going to generalize this code. And as
we saw in the last video, that is exactly why we
are going to use this particular module of Python,
which is just so first, we need to check whether
someone is giving a particular URL as part of the
execution command. So for that, we are going to
include this exception handling module in the
quote, exception is nothing but unexpected error.
So that's why we are calling it Exception Handling
how to handle the exception. So in this section,
what we are doing is we are checking sis dot arg v
arg stands for argument that is passed with the
code execution. So we are seeing if the length
of sis.rb is more than one then we take the first
argument that is passed with the code execution
is we are going to pass this message sis dot
exists. Exit message that says error, please enter
the TED talk you are to demonstrate the output of
this let us go to terminal, let us take the code
that we saved using the previous section. And
then we'll use Python three, and then type this
and see what is the error that you are getting
the error that you are getting this error, please
enter the TED Talk URL. So that is exactly what is
happening here. So we have written this exception
handling module that will tell us error, please
enter the TED Talk URL, which will show up when
someone is just executing the name executing
the file name without passing any argument,
which is what we are checking here. So to check
how the code executes properly, let us actually
take a proper URL of a talk and then we'll
see how to download this entire video as this
is becoming a CLA tool. Now let us save this code.
Let us copy this video URL that we just used hard
coded in the previous video. So now we'll go
to terminal we'll do the same Python three
a talk downloader, and then we'll paste the video
URL, the actual data URL, and let us Press Enter.
And as you can see, these are the messages that
we have given in the previous section download
about the start and end download has started,
we extracted the URL name and then storing in
this particular name, and then it says download
process finished. At the start of this video,
you might have seen that we had only four files
in this particular video or in this particular
folder. But now, as we do LS you can actually
see we have one extra file which is an mp4 file,
which is what we have downloaded. Let us go
into our finder and see we had all these four
files. And now as part of this thing, we have
this file also which is actually a tic toc.
So what we have seen is, we actually built a
first draft code first version of the code that
did not have argument parsing where we hard
coded the URL. In this video, we learned how to
generalize this video generalize this code, which
will include URL as part of an argument and that
URL will be used to download the video and we also
saw how to handle the exception when someone is
not giving the URL as part of the execution
in the terminal. Thank you for listening.
In this section, we'll learn how to build a
table extracted from the PDF file format. pdf
is one of the most prevalent file formats that
we deal with in our daily life. Anyone who works
in data science would know that extracting table
from PDFs is one of the most boring manual tasks
than one have to deal with. In this section.
We'll start with basics of PDF file format,
then we'll learn how to install the required
Python modules for extracting the PDF.
Then we'll actually do the coding part to
extract table from PDF. Then finally, we'll learn
a bit about panda's data frame and then using
panda's data frame to write the table that we just
extracted into a CSV file. Thank you. In the next
video, we'll start with basics of PDF file format.
In this video, we'll learn the basics of PDF file
format. pdf stands for portable document format,
which is a file format developed by Adobe in
the 1990s. This file format was developed to
present documents that include text, graphics and
images, independent of the software and hardware
and operating systems as seen, let us say whether
it is Apple Mac or Microsoft Windows, a document
should look the same in both the operating systems
and both the hardware, hence, PDF was developed.
The first version 1.0 of PDF was introduced in
1993. pdf is based on the PostScript language,
each PDF file encapsulates a complete description
of a fixed layout flat document. The way
that text and graphics are embedded on the PDF
are based on the layout not with any structured
format. The general structure of a PDF file is
composed of four main components header body cross
reference table trailer, the header contains just
one line that identifies the version of the PDF,
for example, percentage PDF 1.5. This indicates
that this PDF belongs to the version 1.5.
The trailer contains pointers to the cross
reference table and two key objects contained
in the trailer dictionary. It ends with percentage
percentage Evo F. To identify end of file, e o f
stands for end of file. The cross reference table
contains pointers to all the objects included
in the PDF. It identifies how many objects
are in the table, where the objects begin,
and its length in bytes. The body contains all
the object information, for example, object
informations like fonts, images, words, bookmarks,
form fields, and so on. So these objects
are mapped using the cross reference table and
thus this forms the structure of the PDF. So far
in this video, we learned the basics of a PDF file
format and the general structure of a PDF file.
In the next video, we'll learn how to install
the required Python packages for this project.
In this video, we'll learn how to install the
required Python packages for this project. So
we need three Python packages for this particular
project. The first one is Jupiter, the second one
is Camelot. And then the third one is shebang,
which we are going to use for data visualization.
So to install Jupiter notebook, we have to
open our terminal and then use the Jupyter
Notebook installation command. Before that,
let us see a bit about Jupyter Notebook.
Jupyter Notebook is an open source web application
that allows you to create and share documents
that contain live code visualization and narrative
text. So Jupyter Notebook is one of the most
preferred IDs are notebooks used in data science
community. And the reason is Jupyter Notebook lets
you write code and also the narrative text in
the form of markdown in the same file format.
Also Jupyter Notebook lead says upload Jupyter
Notebooks rendered file which is a markdown on
web. So if you are going to maintain a web blog,
which is markdown based, so you can export Jupyter
Notebooks markdown file and then upload it on web.
Alternatively, if you want a Python file, not a
Jupyter Notebook, just a Python file to share
it with your peers or automation. Then Jupyter
Notebook also lets you download the file that you
have written the notebook file into.pi format,
so let us go ahead and then install Jupiter
notebook. Open your shell or terminal
where you would be doing this
installation if you're using Mac,
open your terminal and if you are using Windows,
open your command prompt. So once you open your
command prompt, as we have seen in the previous
videos, if you have Python three then you have to
type PIP three for installation of any Python
package and then type install and Jupiter.
Once you type enter, This command will install
Jupyter Notebook on our machine. So it seems
that Jupyter Notebook has been installed. So let
us validate whether Jupyter Notebook has been
successfully installed. So let us type Jupyter
Notebook Enter to invoke the Jupyter Notebook.
As you can see, Jupyter Notebook has been
successfully installed. Now for us to shut
down this notebook. Let us go to the terminal and
then type Ctrl C. So type Ctrl C in your keyboard
to shut down this Jupyter Notebook and it asks
you whether you want to shut down press why that
the Jupyter Notebook has been successfully shut
down so you can see the shutdown configuration.
So the next package that we would like to install
is Camelot. Camelot is the Python package that we
will be using to extract tables from PDF. Camelot
is an open source package that is available on
pi pi. So the same way that we install Jupiter
notebook we can use PIP to install Camelot,
Camelot is the package that we have preferred
in this project to extract table from PDFs.
So let us go ahead and Then install Camelot
package. So now once again type PIP three install
Camelot but the thing with the Camelot packages
instead of just typing Camelot you need to install
Camelot pi The reason is there is already a Python
package in the name of Camelot which is not this
package. So, these package developers decided to
put it in the name Camelot hyphen p y. So, the
package that we should be installing is Camelot
dash p y even though the package name is Camelot,
we have installed it like this. So, let us type
into that the package gets installed on our local
machine. So, we see that the package has been
installed. So, let us verify whether Camelot has
been installed successfully. So, let us open our
Python Client repple. Once we have Python Client,
let us try to import Camelot. So, Camelot has
been successfully imported without any error,
which means Camelot has been successfully
installed. So, let us exit the Python console.
And then the next package that we are interested
in is C one c one is the package that we are going
to use for data visualization. So, as part of this
project, once we extract the table from the PDF,
we are going to visualize it so that the data
science workflow is completed. So seaborne is
the package that we will be installing. So, let
us install c one, let us go ahead and open our
terminal. Let's clear the screen and then type
PIP three, install c mon. Once you type enter,
c one is going to get installed. So C one
ultimately requires matplotlib as a dependency.
So if you have got matplotlib already on your
machine, so C one wouldn't install it again.
But if you have not got it, no problem not plot
lib would also get installed on your machine.
So let us clear the terminal and then verify
whether seaborne has been successfully installed.
So open Python three, input c one. As you can see
c one has been successfully imported, which means
c one installation is successful. So in this
video, we have seen that we installed the required
Python packages, we install three packages,
which are Jupiter or Jupiter notebook, Camelot
for extracting table from PDF and then C one for
data visualization. So in the next video, we'll
start with the coding of how to extract table from
the PDF. Thank you for listening. In this video,
we'll learn how to extract table from a PDF
file. Before we start with the coding part,
let us try to understand what other Python
modules are available for the same purpose.
The first one is tabular. tabular is one of the
most widely used PDF extraction library. tabular
is actually based on a Java library in the same
name tabular. So, this one that we are talking
about is a Python binding for the Java library.
The next one is PDF lumber, then PDF tables
and PDF table extract. So, all these libraries
are available as an alternate for the library
that we have picked for this particular project.
So even though all these libraries are available,
we have selected Camelot to go ahead
with so the reason we selected Camelot is
because of the following reasons. The first
main reason is you are in control. So unlike
other libraries and tools, which gives you a nice
output or failed miserably, so there is no in
between. So either it gives you a nice output or
it fails miserably. Camelot gives you the power to
tweak the table extraction with hyper parameters,
which means if you do not get any output,
then you can tweak your hyper parameters to get at
least some output show that not everything in the
PDF table extraction becomes manual. The reason
is because since everything in the real world
is actually fuzzy, including PDF table extraction
is also fuzzy. You need to have control over
the hyper parameters to tweak how you want to
extract the table from the PDF. The second one is
bad tables can be discarded based on the metrics
like accuracy and whitespace. So Camelot gives
you these metrics accuracy and whitespace so
that you don't have to manually look at each
table to select the good table and discard the
bad table. The next reason is, the table output
that you get out of Camelot is a panda's data
frame. panda's data frame is one of the most
widely used Python module for data analysis
and data science, which means the output of
the Camelot library could be seamlessly integrated
into any ETL workflow or a data analysis workflow,
which exhaustingly uses Camelot or Python. The
last reason is because Camelot lets you export the
extracted PDF table into multiple file formats,
including JSON, XML and HTML. Let us say that the
table that you extracted from the PDF file
format you wanted it to be published online,
which means you ultimately want HTML file
format. So instead of sitting and hard coding,
HTML file format A table HTML table Camelot lets
you export the PDF table that you just extracted
into a HTML file. So this way, Camelot helps you
with being in control, discarding bad tables.
And then using a panda's data frame, which is
easily seamlessly integrated with an existing
data analysis workflow. And then finally exporting
the file format into a different file format.
So this is the reason why we pick Camelot ahead of
the other packages that we just mentioned. So let
us move ahead and then learn how Camelot is going
to help us in extracting tables from PDF. The PDF
from which we would like to extract data is this
PDF. This has been downloaded from un website,
which is economic and Human Development indicators
for India. So this is a fact sheet with multiple
tables. As you can see, you have one table here,
you have another table here, so multiple tables
with multiple columns. So for this particular
purpose, we are interested in extracting the
values row 2021 and 22 of this table, which is
literacy rate. So let us go ahead and see how we,
we are going to extract this particular table and
then do a little bit of data visualization with
this, before we move on to the actual coding,
because this is the first time we are going to
use Jupyter Notebook in our course. So let us see
a bit of overview about Jupyter Notebook. So open
your terminal, which is Windows command prompt
or Mac terminal, and type Jupiter notebook. Once
you take Jupyter Notebook, it would internally
evoke a server and then your Jupyter Notebook,
which this interface would open. And then
for you to create a new Jupyter Notebook,
click here new and then type Python three, click
this Python three. So once you enter here, this is
how the structure of a Jupyter Notebook would
look like. So this is the title which you can
add to say, Okay, my first Jupyter Notebook. So
once we have renamed it, this is how the Jupyter
Notebook would look like. So this in the Jupyter
Notebook would be called as a cell. This cell can
have primarily two values. So it can have a code
value where you can write your Python code. Or it
can have a markdown where you write your narrative
text or documentation. So let's start with the
documentation and say, This is my first Jupyter
Notebook. And then let's say this is a heading.
So once you are done with this thing, this is how
it looks like. So now let us go ahead and write a
small Python code. As you all know, Python can be
also used as a calculator, which means you can do
basic arithmetic operation. So let us go ahead and
do a little bit of arithmetic operation which says
three into three. Once you are done with this
code, you can press Shift Enter, like this,
and then the output will be displayed. Or maybe
if you do not want to use the keyboard shortcut,
you can say okay, four minus three, which is
probably one and then we'll go ahead and click
Run button here, which will show us output one. So
this way, you know that you can have documentation
or narrative text and then code in the same
file. And then this is the advantage of Jupyter
Notebook. And one of the reasons why we prefer
Jupyter Notebook for this particular project.
Now, let us go ahead and start executing
the actual code that we would like to write
for extracting table from the UN report that we
just saw. So to start with, we should name the
Jupyter Notebook, which is a good practice.
So in this case, we can name it extracting
table from PDF. So whatever you would like to name
you can name it so I've named it extracting table
from PDF. The first Excel let us start with
importing the Camelot package. In this case,
I'm importing the Camelot package with an alias
which is cm which will help us easily call that
evoke that package. So let us go here and say
Shift Enter. On the Jupyter Notebook successfully
installed, you get this thing probably let's say
if you have made a mistake instead of Camelot,
we have said cam as cm. Now, you will get an error
that this module is not found, because there is
no such package cam in this particular Python
environment. So once we successfully invoke or
call that package, we will not get any error, but
the package has been imported. So next step is for
us to see what are all the files available in the
environment. So we see these are the files that we
have in that environment. So we have the PDF file
that is available in the current folder. We have
the CSV and XLS, which I just executed before the
project and I have it in place. And then we have
a bunch of other files. So now let us go ahead and
then import the file. There are two ways that you
can read PDF one, you can read it directly from
web like from where we have downloaded the PDF,
or you can read it from your local machine. So
the first argument is you read you give the Python
the PDF file name the second argument In this
flavor, which is there are two ways Camelot
can parse your PDF file one is called stream.
The other one is called a dice mod. These have
different variety of ways to how to parse a PDF
file. And in this particular case, we will prefer
lattes. And then we are explicitly telling
Camelot that we have two pages one is page one,
the second one is page two. So we are going
to use the function named read underscore PDF
from Camelot and then we are going to read the
PDF file. So let us execute this shift enter. Once
we execute this thing, we are writing it in the
Python object input underscore PDF. So we can see
that this has been successfully executed without
any error. So now, let us see what is inside that
input underscore PDF. So this gives you a
table list object with four values inside it,
which means there are four tables that has been
extracted from this function from this video.
And this has been put inside this into input
underscore PDF as a table file. So for us
to know what are the individual properties
individual dimensions of this particular PDF
extraction process, we will see four n in input
underscore PDF, so we are iterating in through
input underscore PDF to see what is inside it.
So let us go ahead and execute this thing. So
this shows that we have four PDF table extracted
files, which is first one is the table is with
the dimension four by three, which means four
rows, three columns, second known as 15 by three,
the third one is 14 by four, and then the fourth
one is 13 by three, so our area of interest is
the last part of the first page, as you saw in the
previous PDF display. So we are going to say okay,
I want this third one. Since Python is a zero
indexed language, we will say two input underscore
PDF of two. And then we are saying Do you mean
it as a data frame. So once we write this thing,
this is what we get. As you can see, this is our
area of interest, which is the literacy rate,
and which is the index value 1112, and 13. So
what we are going to do now is we are going to say
okay, I want input underscore PDF of two,
and then from that I want the data frame.
And in that give me the location leaven to 14
and then give me three columns, which is 123.
So I want 123 11 1213. That is what we are
specifying here. Once we execute this thing,
we can see how the different looks like. So this
is how the extractor table looks like. So let us
do a little bit of table formatting. Before we
do table formatting. We have understood that
this data frame that Camelot gives us as
part of a panda's data frame. So let us
have a little bit of understanding of pandas.
pandas is the data manipulation package that
is widely used the most widely used for Python,
and pandas helps you read a CSV, write a CSV,
read an Excel write in Excel, do a little bit of
reformatting in case if you want to, you know,
do a little bit of data analysis, pandas will
help you do data preparation data pre processing.
So like that, what we are going to do is we
are going to use a panda's function which is
reset index to drop this index value 1112 and
three, and then come up with our own index value,
which is by default 0123. So let us go ahead and
say, okay, for this data frame, dot t does reset
underscore index drop is equal to true and then
we'll assign it to the data frame here. So let
us go ahead and execute this thing. And then let's
see how the output looks like. Now as you can see,
from 11 1213, it has become 012. Now as
you can see, there are three columns,
but the column names are 123, which is not
very intuitive if you want to write a table.
So what we'll do is we'll manually put the table
name. So from the table, you can you can see that
this is 2001 This is 2011. And these are the KPIs
that we are interested in. So what we'll do is
we'll say Okay, the first column is Kp, second
is 2,001/3 is 2011. Let us execute this thing.
And then let us see how the output looks like.
So from one to three, now it has become kPa
to those n one and two those 11 then the next
step is for us to do any kind of data analysis
with this thing, we need to convert this one which
is actually a string into a number format. And the
number format that we are going to use is float
because this is a decimal point. So from string,
we are going to save for 2001 and 2011. convert
everything to float. So once we do this thing,
we are reassigning it to the same old data
frame, and then the output even though it
looks same internally from string, it has become
a character. The next step is for us to write
the output as a CSV file. So because this
file name is already available, we'll say
Pac output dot CSV. So once we have written the
CSV, we can go ahead and See using ls command
to see how the current working directory looks
like. So as you can see, we have packed underscore
output dot CSV, which is what we just wrote using
pandas function, which is to underscore CSV.
Once we are done with this thing, I would like to
add another information that pandas is not just
letting you write it as a CSV, but it can help you
write it as an Excel file. So let us go ahead and
then use this function to underscore Excel on this
panda's data frame to write it as an excellent,
let's say, packed output Excel with the extension
dot x LS x. And then once we execute this thing,
let us see how the current directory looks like.
So in the previous setup, you had only packed
underscore output dot CSV. But now you can also
see that at underscore output underscore Excel
dot XLS x. So this is how the Excel file looks
like. So as we write it, so now what we can do is
we would like to import this in our current
working directory in this current Python session,
so that we can do some data analysis. So our
objective in this project is to read table
and then write that output table as a
CSV, which we have already achieved.
But as a bonus, I would like to also show you
why we would be requiring such a data frame in
the first place, because we want to do some data
analysis, some data visualization from the PDF
file, which we cannot do it directly. So we are
extracting the table from the PDF as a CSV as a
data frame, which is then we are converting it as
a CSV. And then we are doing some data analysis
with this. In this case, we'll build a bar graph
with this. So let us go ahead and call our panda's
data frame, which is required for us to read
the CSV. So as we call the panda's data frame,
we'll say PD dot read underscore CSV. And what
is the name of the file that we wrote. It is
packed underscore output dot CSV. So
we'll replace this name with this name.
And then we'll say read underscore CSV. And
then we are assigning it to a Python object
which is the DF two and then we'll display how
it looks like. So once we execute this thing.
We can see this is how it looks like with an index
value because we just read it, then we'll call a
data visualization library c one c one is one of
the most widely used data visualization library.
Seaborn is actually built on matplotlib for
better visualizations. So we'll go ahead and
call Seabourn with an area's SNS once we are done
with that, executed, Seabourn is now imported.
So, for us to build a data visualization, we
have to change the format the shape of how the
data frame looks like to a different shape. So,
we are going to use the pandas function melt,
which will convert this data frame from the wide
format to a long format. So, this is called to be
a wide format. Now, we are going to convert it to
a long format. Now, let us execute this thing once
we execute df underscore melt is available now,
let us see how df underscore meant is available.
So as you can see, this is a wide format. Now,
this is a long format frame where 2001 and 2011
from being the column name that has become the row
value and the value that we have given us here and
percentage. Now the DF underscore melted is
available, let us go ahead and then make a bar
plot. So we are going to use acns dot bar plot for
making a bar plot the x axis should contain the Kp
value, the y axis should contain the percentage
and the Q which is the grouping variable,
which is 2011 and 2001. For us to compare how
it has been different for 2011 and in 2001.
Let us execute this thing. As you
can see, now it has generated a plot
with two bars, the blue color represent to version
one, the orange color represents 2011. And then
with three KPIs that we just built, literacy
rate male literacy rate or female literacy rate.
So this is how the overall literacy rate and as
you can see the gap between 2001 and 2011 female
literacy rate is huge, which means there has
been a tremendous growth between 2001 and 2011
in the rate of female literacy rate. So this is
what we have understood from this project that
we had a raw PDF file which was unreadable
as it is not a structured information. What
we have done is we have used Camelot to read the
PDF, which is to be technical, we parse the PDF,
we extracted tables, specifically we extracted
four tables. We went to the table of our interest,
which is index 1112 and three, and then we did a
little bit of data pre processing using pandas.
Once we did the data pre processing,
we went ahead and then we wrote
the data frame. into a CSV file. And we also
experimented with writing it as an Excel file.
Once we were done with this Excel file, we finally
went and did a little bit of data pre processing,
which is reshaping the data from a wide
format to long format. And then finally,
we explored the data as a data visualization to
understand some valuable insight from the PDF that
we have returned show for. In this video tutorial,
we learned how to build a table extracted from
PDF. So we started with understanding the PDF
file formats. Then we went ahead and installed
Camelot and Jupyter Notebook Python packages.
Then we understood how to extract PDF table.
And then we saw basics of panda's data frame
to write and read CSV. And then we went ahead
with seaborne to do some visualization. So at
the end of this project, we have a successful
visualization, we have the output table as
CSV and Excel. And then we also learned how
to extract table from any PDF. So thank you for
listening. I'll see you in the next section.
In this section, we'll learn how to
build an automated bulk resume parser.
Going through resumes, and extracting relevant
information from those resumes is one of the most
essential tasks a manager has to go through before
hiring new resources. In this section, we'll learn
how to build an automated bulk resume a parser
that can go through multiple resumes and extract
relevant information from them, and convert
them into a structured tabular format. with
the click of a button. We'll start the section
by understanding different formats of resumes,
and marking relevant information that we would
like to extract a brief overview of packages and
the installation of those packages. Then we'll
see the basics of regular expression in Python,
and also the basic overview of spacey
functions. And then we'll move on to
build the code to extract relevant information.
And then finally, we'll complete the script.
To make it one click command level tool.
Let us go ahead and then see the sections.
In this video, we'll learn the different formats
of resumes. And then we'll mark essential
information that we would like to extract in this
project. So as you can see, on my screen, I've got
two different types of resumes. The first one is
a single column, which has content one by one. And
then the second one is a double column, which
means in one page, they have got two columns,
and then the experiences and other details are
scattered across the columns. So as you can see,
a resume can have me multiple types. So
it is up to the creator of the resume,
essentially the one who is seeking for a job to
have the format that he or she likes. But it is
essential for the recruiting manager to completely
go through the resume to extract essential parts
of it. So what do we mean by essential parts?
The first one is I would say that the name,
the name, to whom this resume belongs
is the most essential part because
if you ever want to shortlist this resume, you
need to understand who is that person. And then
the second thing is, if you ever want to shortlist
a resume, you just do not want to know their name,
but also you need to be able to contact them. And
then the two key information to contact a person,
one their email ID, and then the second one their
phone number. So as you can see in this resume,
the name is first of all mentioned in the top
left, but in this regime as the name is in the
center position. And in this resume, the email
id is in the top right, but in this resume,
it is all centrally aligned. So as you can see,
we have totally listed down three elements. The
first one is name, the second one is email
id. And then the third one is a phone number.
These are the three information significant
information that we would like to extract
from this resume. But more than this, what
we want to do is we want to have a criteria
for which we want to extract this resume,
which means for example, let us say you are
recruiting for a position called data scientist.
And for a position called data scientists you
need to have relevant resume is who have the
essential skills of a data scientist and that is
the most important information that we would like
to see in the resume extraction project. So for
that purpose, we are going to extract skills from
this resume, especially to say technical skills.
So the things that we are going to extract is most
importantly the technical skills from the resume,
then the name, phone number, email id irrespective
of how or where these informations are present
in a particular resume. We are going to extract
this information using this particular project.
Before we move on, we have to also understand
one more thing. That resume itself is a file
and then the file could have multiple formats.
For example, a resume could be a simple image of
JPEG or PNG The resume a could be a doc exe, which
is Microsoft Word, or the resume could be of PDF.
In this particular project, we are going
to only deal with the resumes of PDF type.
Because once we have written a script for PDF file
format, it is not very tough for you to convert
every other format into a PDF format. Let's say
you can convert a JPEG to a PDF format, you can
convert a docx to a PDF format. So, that is one of
the reasons why we have picked PDF format as one
condition where we will build this project upon so
PDF is the file format that we are going to use.
And also that we are going to use resumes
of different types it could be single or
double column. And then the information
is that we are going to extract a skill
name, email id and phone number. In the next
video, we'll see the architecture of this project,
and then the required Python modules
and how to install those Python modules.
In this video, we'll see the architectural
overview of this project. So in this project
will take three PDF files shall resume is in
three PDF files. And we will store it in our local
folder. So what we are going to do is we are going
to take one PDF file from this folder, and then
we'll convert this PDF into text. And then
we'll do natural language processing and
pattern matching to extract relevant information
that are required the relevant information that
we saw in the previous video, which are
name, email id, phone number, and skills.
And then we'll use these relevant information
to populate a structured tabular format.
And then finally, we'll write the output in a CSV
format. Meanwhile, while we are doing PDF to text,
we also would save those PDF files as text files
for future reference. We'll iterate this process
until all the files in the current
directory which is the folder
are completed. Sure to repeat, we are going to
take PDF files, convert them into PDF to text,
then do natural language processing and pattern
matching. And then we are going to populate them
in a structured tabular format. And then we are
going to write it in a CSV. So for this purpose,
these are the packages that we are going to use.
The first one is PDF minor for PDF to text, then
spacey for natural language processing, then our
E rejects package that is for pattern matching,
and pandas per output CSV saving. Meanwhile, we
also would use another package called ODS. This
is for operating system manipulation, which
is highly required for us to iterate through
multiple files and in the current working
directory, and also to save the output files
in the required folder. So the packages that
we will be using are PDF minor, spacey, r, e,
OAS, and pandas. So of all these five packages,
packages, ie underwears come by default installed
on your Python operating system. So of all these
five packages, packages, Ari and OAS are already
installed by default in your Python environment.
So it is required for us to install PDF minor,
spacey, and pandas. As we just saw, of the five
required Python packages. Two packages come by
default with your Python installation. Those
are our UI, and OAS. So we'll go ahead and see
how to install the rest of the packages which
is PDF minor, spacey, and pandas to start with
PDF minor is a package that we are going to use to
convert a PDF into text. And the package that we
are going to use is called PDF minor dot six
for that reason is because PDF minor is the
actual package name whose development stopped
before python 2.7. So there was a requirement
to support the latest version of Python. And that
is where this fork as you can see, this is a fork
of PDF minor. And this is called PDF minor dot
six. So anytime you're going to deal with PDF,
and then you want the PDF to be converted into a
text format, and then you have got Python version
which is latest, mostly three, then you have
to install PDF miner dot six, not PDF miner.
So as we have always seen how to install a Python
package in this project also will use a terminal
or shell or Command Prompt. And then we'll use
PIP to install the required Python package.
So let us open our terminal or in case if
you have got windows mission command prompt
and type PIP three, install PDF minor dot six. So
as I've got already this package on my machine,
this is successfully shown that it has been
satisfied. Now let us open our Python terminal
to see if PDF Minor has been successfully
installed. So let us try import PDF minor.
You can notice this difference that when we
install the package, it is called PDF minor dot
six. But when we import it it is as same as PDF
minor. So the only reason they have got this dot
six is to differentiate between the older version
of PDF minor and the newer version of PDF minor.
So let us type PDF, import PDF minor and then
press enter and then you can see that it has been
successfully imported without any error, which
means PDF minor has been successfully imported.
The next Python package that
we would like to install is
spacey. spacey is the library that we are going
to use for natural language processing. In fact,
spacey is one of the most popular natural
language processing libraries in Python and it is
widely used in the industry for natural language
processing. There are a lot of features of spacey
for example, the tokenization is very good, it has
got a good named entity recognition, it has got a
very good language support like 49 languages are
supported. It also comes with pre trained models,
which helps us do a lot of natural language
processing without training our own model. So
let us go ahead and install spacey. So to install
spacey, we can see that again we will use PIP and
then we'll do install spacey. And if you remember
one of the things that I've told from our previous
sections, we use PIP three because our Python
version is Python three in case if you have got
Python you have to use the so PIP three install
spacey. So as you can see requirement is already
satisfied because I've got this package already.
So it has been successfully installed. Let us
clear our terminal and then open Python three to
see if spacey has been successfully installed.
So Python three import spacey. spacey has been
successfully imported, let us exit. But there
is one more thing that we have to do with respect
to spacey, which is download the language model.
So a natural language processing can work better
only if the language model is available, which
usually has got all these words and then the
part of speech the named entity recognition
all this stuff. So for us to download the default
language model English language model for spacey,
we have to use this command, which we'll
put in our terminal. And because we have
got Python three, we'll do Python three spacey
download. So, once this is successfully done,
our language model is successfully installed.
So we can see that the language model has been
installed. And then it is also telling us that
the way we have loaded our language models,
spacey dot load the language model. So let us just
check that once. Let us open our Python terminal
and then say import spacey and then copy
this and then say okay, my NLP is equal to
Yeah, the language model has been successfully
loaded, which means we have got successfully
installed spacey and that language model that is
required for us to do English natural language
processing. And then the final library
that we are going to install is pandas.
pandas is the library, the go to library for any
tabular data manipulation, and pandas is one of
the most widely used library in data science for
data manipulation. So it is much easier for us
to install pandas. As the name suggests, we'll
do let's clear our terminal to three installed
pandas. We can see that the requirement has
been satisfied. Let us open our Python terminal
unsay input pandas. pandas has been successfully
imported without any error, which means we have
successfully installed the packages that
are required for us, which is PDF minor,
and then spacey, and then pandas. But we also
saw that there are other two libraries that comes
by default in the current Python installation
that we have got. So let us just verify
whether those packages are available. So the
first package that we saw was our E, which
is for regular Express manipulation. So we'll do
import IE. Yep, that's been successfully imported.
And then the next package that we saw was
was for operating system manipulation,
to you know, find files, pass through folders.
So we'll do input was, and as we can see,
these two libraries are successfully
imported, which means we are all set
with all the libraries that are required
for us to proceed with this project.
And then we'll see how to code. In the next
section. We'll see basics of regular expression
and natural language processing overview
and then we'll move on to coding. Thank you.
In this video, we'll learn basics of
regular expression. Regular Expression
could be also called as regex or red X or
reg x. So whatever you would like to call it
is a sequence of characters that define a search
pattern. That search pattern is usually the
combination of characters and meta characters.
So the meta characters are like this cap,
dollar dot pipe or curly braces. So these meta
characters define the syntax around characters
to create the search pattern, which is what we
call as regular expression. regular expression
is one of the toughest programming concepts
that is not very familiar. So there are a lot
of names around regular expressions on internet,
you can just refer to it to see how tough it is.
So just to understand regular expression,
we'll go through a little bit basics,
but regular expression is so old that
anytime you Google for regular expression,
you would find the answer for which you're
searching for. So, the basics of expression is
primarily to understand the meta characters,
the meta character pipe, the pipe operator
defines a Boolean or so, if you want to compare
between two words, whether it is gi AY or GY,
then you would use a pipe operator in your
regular expression. So, then parenthesis, let
us assume that you do not want to use individual
different words, but you want to just use or for
one particular character, then you would use gr,
open parenthesis a pipe e close parenthesis, which
is to say I want gr and then it could be either
A or D and then I want to wipe So, this is how
my pattern should look like. And this is what we
call a grouping regular expression metacharacters
also has something called quantification,
which is to say, how many or how the number
of elements or tokens should be present in the
pattern that I would like to see. For example,
the question mark indicates zero or one
occurrence of the preceding element, which means
let us say you have got color CEO elbow you
question mark and our which means it could
match both CEO elbow our our CFO elbow, you our
while question mark is about one Li one occurrence
as strict which is star is about multiple
occurrences. Which means if you say a B star C,
it could be either a, b, c, or it could
be either ABC, or it could be either ABC
or so on. So it doesn't strictly count only one
occurrence of the preceding character. But it
actually has n number of preceding characters
that you could have. But the condition is that
you have to have a and b and c. So this is the
basic concept of regular expression. But you could
actually refer more online to understand more of
regular expression. But for us to proceed with
this project, I think this is good enough for us
to see how to build a basic regular expression,
or at least to understand the regular expression
that we might get from internet. So now, from
the basics of regular expression. As such, we'll
move forward to see how these regular expressions
could be used in Python for us to do pattern
matching. And as we saw in the previous video,
the package that we are going to use for regular
expression in Python is R E. So Ari has these
major functions match search, find all split,
sub and compile. So all of these you will see
compile is something that would be mostly used to
create a regular expression, and then compile it,
and then use that compiled regular expression to
find and search for everything else. And match is
when you would use if you want to match the first
word and search, you don't care about whether it
is first or second word, but you will want to
find it anywhere it isn't. And find all again it
has its own purpose. So let us open our terminal
and then see a little bit of regular expression,
how we would like to do it. So you can open either
your terminal or your Python console on pi charm
or Jupyter Notebook. But for simplicity,
I'm just invoking Python from my terminal,
then say import IE. And let us create a
sample text. Okay, my text is going to say
best Python course this is my text. And now
I would like to see where the word based
if the word based occurs in my text, so first
I'm going to say re dot match of paste, which
is my search pattern here, in this case, regular
expression. Comma, I'm going to save my text
and then enter. So as you can see, it has replied
with a real object, understand zero to four which
means I've got the word best. And the match
is best. But let's say we want to test it
with two different words either best or let's say
good match but we are going to use pipe operator
to say good so it says the matches best
because the text is saying We have got
best Python course, let us create a second text,
which is text to. And in this case, we'll say good
Python course. And then we'll use the same regular
expression that we used before which is best pipe
good, which means either best or good and
then say text to in this case, it says that
it has matched with good, and then it is the same
space. Now what we'll do is instead of using match
in this will use good best Python course
aspects too. And then instead of using match,
we'll use search to see what output it gives
us. As you can see, it has matched good,
because we have got either based or good and then
index two and the position is good based Python
course, let us assume now we want to see both both
of these in the given text. So now we'll say T dot
find all which will result us both
good and best. So, in this case,
we wanted to see whether both these words are
present and then because both these words are
present, it is returning us both good
and best that it is present in the text.
And in case if the pattern that we have given
the regular expression that we have given us,
let's say something like this, and then it
is not available and then we will not get
any result which is we have got an empty
list. So these are the main functions
that we are going to use in this particular
project. So this is a very brief introduction
of regular expression, and also how to use regular
expression in Python for pattern matching. In
the next video, we will see very basics of
natural language processing using spacey.
In this video, we will learn basics of natural
language processing using spacey. So let us open
our Jupyter Notebook and create a new Jupyter
Notebook. So you can do this by going to File
and then new notebook and select Python three
once you have this new notebook. Let us now
see a little bit about spacey. So as we saw in
the previous video, spacey is one of the most
popular used natural language processing library.
So we'll import the library using import spacey.
Once that is done, the very first step,
the next step that we are supposed to do is
load our language model. So if you
remember after installing spacey library,
we downloaded the English language model.
So if you remember, after installing spacey
Python library, we actually downloaded the
English language model because a language
model is essential for a lot of natural language
processing tasks. So, we are going to load the
language model that we downloaded in the previous
section. So we will use spacey dot load and then
put the name of the language model that you have
downloaded. For example, let us assume that you
have downloaded a language model for a different
language like German, so you will have a different
name instead of E. And so in that case, put the
language model name that you have downloaded.
And then as I need to NLP. So once this is
successfully executed, now what you can do
is you can define the text that you have. So
the text that I've got is I've got a couple of
sentences from Google Wikipedia page for us to
explore this package. So I'm going to use this
as text and then I'm assigning it to text. So if
you print text you will see okay, this is my text.
So what are we going to do now is now that the
entire thing is ready. So we have imported the
package, we have loaded the language model
and then the input text on which we have to
do natural language processing is ready. So the
first step in natural language processing is
annotation. So what you're going to do
is you're going to let the language model
annotate your input text, so that the input
text is created in such a way that it knows
what is a part of speech tagging in it, it
knows where are the named entity recognition,
it tokenizers it it creates word vectors it can
do a lot of other things. So the first step is
use the language model because you loaded the
language model and presented to NLP on the text
input text that you have got. So the way you do
is NLP off text and then you store the result
in doc. So once you store the result in dog the
first very first step that any natural language
processing would require you to do is tokenization
what is tokenization tokenization is nothing but
splitting the input text based on token so for
example, so in this case what we are going to do
is we are going to split the entire text word by
word so word is the token for us here. So you can
do the sentence organization. You can do this even
paragraph tokenization but in this case we are
going to do word tokenization. So say we have got
doc so let us print how the doc looks like once I
print doc. I'm not getting anything other than
this thing because this is what it is printing,
but internally doc has been annotated using the
natural language processing light library and
language model that we have got. So what are we
going to do is we are going to say for token and
doc print token so we are going to iterate through
doc and then say okay print each and every token
by default, which is a word token. So we
what we see is, we see one by one word by
word. And then okay the word organization has been
successfully then, once the word tokenisation has
been successfully done, we can do a lot of things.
For example, you can build a workload if you want,
you can build a unigram or if you want, you can
have a bi gram also combining the words. In case
let's say you want to visualize the sentence,
instead of doing word tokenization, you can do
a sentence tokenization. So the opportunities
are a lot so you can do anything you want.
To move ahead with the spacey library, what we can
further do is as we saw, when you annotate your
input text using the language model that you have
got you get out of speech also part of speeches
to say okay, this this word is a noun, this word
is a verb, this word is an adjective. So all these
things, so what we are going to do now is we are
going to say okay, for token and Doc, the same
thing that we saw before, what we are saying onely
if that token dot POS underscore, which is to say
that this is the part of speech, which is noun,
then print the token. So print all the tokens,
which is known that is what we are going to do
here. So you see that you have got founder Money,
money, Angel, all these things. It is say instead
of now let's say we want to work. So once you
exude this, you get was funded. But in case if
you want objective, you put a DJ, and then you get
all the objectives that you have got. So this
is how you extract a particular part of speech,
for example, you're doing text summarization,
or you're doing any other text technique,
you want to extract topic from it. So you're going
to only go for nouns and adjectives. So the same
way for you to identify a particular part of
speech. So this is what you're going to use,
iterate through the document. For every token,
you're going to say, give me the product speech.
So the next important thing or in fact, the most
important thing for this particular project is
named entity recognition. So what does named
entity recognition, named entity recognition is
nothing but identifying entity of that particular
word. For example, Google is an organization,
August 1998 is a date. When you
have money dollars, it is money,
when you see a person's name, it is a person. So
identifying, you know putting a context around the
word instead of just simply saying, whether it is
a grammatically noun or verb or adverb adjective.
So you're trying to say okay, this is what
I have identified this entity. So that is
what we are calling us named entity recognition.
And this is much, much easier to do and spacey,
because of the language model that
we have got under spacey has made it
so easy for us to do it in one single
function. So what we are going to do is,
we are going to say dot.ns, which will apply the
entity recognition on the dog. So in the previous
section, you would have seen that we have done it
only on dog because we were iterating through the
actual words. But in this case, we want to iterate
through the entities. So we are saying dog.ns,
which is for entities, and then we are iterating
over it with entity. And then we are saying okay,
print entity dot text, the actual word, and then
print entity dot label underscore, which means
the label of the entity that has been recognized.
So I'm printing the word, and I'm printing the
label of the entity, which is organization or data
or whatever it is. So once I print this thing,
this is what I get. So once I print this thing,
so we have entity dot txt, entity dot label
underscore, I'm going to print this and once I
print this thing, and this is what I get, so I get
Google org, or augusztus. August 1998 is a date
and Google is an organization, Jeff Bezos CEO of
Amazon is a person and then Stanford University
is an organization. So this is the way what we are
going to do is we are going to take the text and
then identify important entities that are present
in this text. So this is the basic overview of
natural language processing. Using spacey Of
course, natural language processing is an emerging
area in research and development. And of course,
one of the most widely, you know anticipated areas
in machine learning and artificial intelligence.
So learning natural language processing
with just five cells in Jupyter Notebook is
completely impossible, but just wanted to give you
a flavor of what we might be doing in this course,
so that you have some idea of you know how to
proceed further or if you want to extend this
particular project to include different set of
skills, or different variables that we have not
captured in this resume parsing project. So you
can use this understanding that we have covered
in this video to extend this particular project
to you know, wider objective. So in this video,
we successfully learned the basics of
natural language processing using spacey
we saw a couple of spacey functions how
to load spacey, how to learn natural
language processing the library English language
library, and then we also saw a little bit about
tokenization and named entity recognition. In
the next video we will actually start with the
coding part of resume parsing project which
we are interested In this particular project
In this video, we'll learn how to code the actual
project of resume parsing. Before we get into
coding, there is a little bit of understanding of
folder structure is required. So let us see our
folders are organized for this particular project,
we need to create two different folders that are
essential for this particular project. The first
one is resume his resume is is the folder where we
will have all the input files all the resumes that
we have got in this project. So in this project,
we have taken three resumes and all those three
resumes will be present inside this folder
resumes, then the next folder that we would need
is output folder, which will have two subfolders.
The first one is txt. txt. txt will contain all
the text converted format of those resumes. So
once the resume a PDF is read, and then converted
into a txt that is stored inside this text folder,
and then once the entire parsing is done, all
this content is converted into a structured
tabular format, which is a CSV and then
it is stored inside this folder CSV. So
first, we need resume is folder where we will
have all the PDFs that we want to be parsed.
Second, we will have output folder inside
output folder, we will have two subfolders.
One is txt and then the second one is CSV. Once
you are done with creating these folders, the next
important file that we need for this particular
project is PDF to txt dot p y. So the file that
we need is PDF to txt dot p y. And how do we
get this file. This is a file that is present
inside the PDF miner library. So we need to get
this file from the PDF miner library. So let us
go ahead and then open the PDF minor PDF minor
dot six to be precise PDF minor dot six GitHub
repository. And then let us go inside the tool
section. So open PDF, miners GitHub repository,
and then get into Tools section. So from this tool
section, you can see that you have PDF to text
dot p y, click this. And then you get
RAW file. Once you click the raw file.
You have this option when you press Ctrl S, or
if you're using Mac Command S or you can use your
Firefox to say OK, save pages, which will tell you
okay, how do I have to save the file. So once you
have this file, saved in your local drive
the folder where you have what this project,
now we are ready to go further with the
coding. So there are three essential things
to folders, main folders, output and resumes.
And inside output we want txt and CSV to folders.
And then we need to get this PDF to text dot p
y from the PDF minor GitHub repository and then
store it inside the current working directory
the current folder where this project is setup.
Once this is done, let us go ahead and open our
Jupyter Notebook. So until now, what we saw is
how the folder structure is organized, and what
is the essential file that we need that we source
just from PDF miner GitHub repository.
Once this is done, let us go ahead and open
our Jupyter Notebook. Once you open the Jupyter
Notebook, please create a new notebook by just
going into file, new notebook Python three. Once
you do this thing, your new notebook will be ready
in the new notebook as we have a better coding
practice in the every project that we have done.
Once you create the new notebook by
going to File, New notebook Python three,
we will have a new notebook. And as a better
coding practice, we will start with importing the
library that are required and then we'll create
functions that are acquired and then finally
will invoke those functions and we have got the
entire project set up in the Jupyter Notebook. So
this is the flow that we are going to follow while
creating the Jupyter Notebook. So the first one is
we are going to load all the packages that are
required for this project. So if you remember
from the previous videos that we need five
essential packages. The first one is spacey
for natural language processing, PDF miner for
PDF to text. re r e for rejects, works well as
operating system OAS for file manipulation and
then finally pandas for CSV tabular format.
So pandas for CSV tabular format, once this
is done, let us execute this thing. Next we
are going to input the file PDF to dot txt dot
p y. So next we are going to import PDF to text
dot p y. Next we are going to import PDF to
text dot p y that we just downloaded from the
Google tab repository that we have kept it in our
current working directory is a project folder. So
what we are going to do is we are going to simply
say import PDF to txt. And then we are going to
execute this, this is successfully executed,
which means we have got the file in the right
Drive folder location. So the next task is the
first function that we are going to create is
for converting PDF to txt, and we'll call
this function convert underscore PDF. So this
function is going to take one argument. So this
function is going to take one argument, which is
the file name. So the file name is going to be
given inside this function, and then we'll see
what is this function is going to do. So the first
thing is once we get the file name that is passed
into this function, we are going to say okay,
split the file name, and then had dot txt. So,
imagine you have got a file name, let us
say, okay, observe Majid, which is my name,
and PDF, this is our typical resume might look
like. So what we are trying to do is we are trying
to create the output file name. So because when
we are going to convert the PDF into text, we also
want to save the text in the folder that we just
saw. So what we want to do is we want to create
an output file name using this input file name.
So when we use always dot path dot split text
on the input file name, what we get is we get two
items just like this. So we get two items. So what
we are trying to do is we are going to take the
first one because Python is zero index language,
we are going to take the first one like
this, and then we are saying okay plus text,
which uses the new output file name for the
text file, and then we are assigning this name
to the output file name. So understand that we
got the input file name like this, a PDF file,
and we are trying to remove that extension
dot PDF. And then we are trying to append this
new expression that is dot txt. And then this new
extension dot txt is appended to this filename,
and then this name is getting assigned to this
output underscore file name. Once this is done,
we also have to define where do we want
to save this file. So as we saw just now,
in the folder structure that we are going to have
an output folder. And inside that output folder,
we are going to have all the txt files. So what
we are going to write here is we are saying Okay,
give me the path, which is output slash txt
slash and then this output file name that we
just created. So our output file is going to be
saved in this file path where it is output slash
txt slash, and then the file name output file
name with dot txt extension. So this one,
we are going to assign it in output underscore
file path. The next thing is the PDF to txt that
we just imported, it has a main function,
and then it takes a couple of arguments.
So what we want to do is we want to save this
file in that particular location. So we are
going to say okay, the arguments that I'm passing
is the file name, which I just received, and then
the output file name, which is passed down with
this argument, hyphen, hyphen, outfile, and then
the output file path where it has to be saved. So,
this is the function that helps us converting PDF
to text and save it in the given location, which
is what we create here. So, the output location is
created here, output file name is created here. So
the input file, which is the dot PDF file is given
through this F and then the output file is saved.
Once that is done, we would like to present a
message to the user saying that the file has been
successfully saved this is just for reference.
And finally, we are going to return the
output file path and then we are reading
it as an input file. So what we are doing
is in the same function, we are outputting,
the read file so that is why we have got open the
file name and then dot read which is a function
to read any file in Python. So ideally, we
could have done it in two lines to say okay,
I'm reading the file, and then I'm passing
that read object the file object as returning,
but in to save space and also for simplicity,
which is one of the core philosophies of Python
to have simple code, what we are trying to do is
we are trying to do it in same line. So the file
path which we are reading after opening,
so, this is what we are going to return.
So, in this function convert underscore PDF, there
are five things that we are doing the first thing
is we are creating the output file name. Second
thing is we are creating the output file path.
And then the third thing is we are converting PDF
to txt and saving it in the given location which
is the output file path. Then we are printing
a user message to say that this is successfully
done and then finally we are returning the read
file opened and read file with To be just saved
and then with this, this function is done, let us
execute this function. And this is just for sample
we don't need I'll delete this cell. Once this is
done, now we are going to use spacey to load the
language model. So let us load the language model
in this line which we just saw, load the language
model. Once we have the language model, we are
going to create an output file structure. So
we saw that the ultimate objective of this
project is to capture four important content
four important components from the resume and
then make it a structured document which is name,
phone, email skills, and then these are going to
be the four columns that we have in our output
tabular format. And for that, we are creating a
dictionary a Python dictionary using the curly
braces. So if you remember your basics of Python,
a Python dictionary is created using curly braces,
a Python list is created using your square
brackets. So, what we are trying to do is we are
trying to create a result dictionary and then we
are also creating four placeholder values names,
phones, emails skills, and then we are making it a
list so that when we extract these information, we
can put that particular component the respective
component for example, let us assume that we have
extracted name from the first resume a secondary
email address, so we have three names, and those
three names will go into the placeholder list that
we have created names, the phone numbers will go
into phones, the email ids will go into emails
and then the skills will go into skills. So, with
this, we are ready with the placeholder the type
of output that we would like to have Once this is
done, we are getting into the core function which
is going to extract the content from the resuming.
So with the placeholder output now, we are moving
forward to see how to define the function that
will do the extraction the core for component
extraction for this particular project. Now
that we have got the output placeholder in place,
which is a dictionary and then couple of lists to
put the content inside it extracted content inside
it, we are moving forward to do the actual core
component extraction part of this particular
project. And this function will call it as
parse underscore content, which is to parse
the content that we have, and the argument is
text. So this function receives text, if you
remember, what we returned from this function is
the Convert PDF function is we opened the file
and then we read it, which is a file object
and then in this function, we are going to read a
text. So that is how we are interlinking those two
functions, and we'll see it in the future. So, the
first thing that is required for us is to define
what skill set that we are expecting to extract
from this project. So extract from the resume.
So, the first thing that we have to define is what
are the set of skills the skill set that we would
like to extract from the resuming. So, considering
a data science setup, what we are trying to do is
we are trying to see okay, I want Python and if
you remember your rejects, you might remember
that a pipe operator signifies or condition, so
Python or Java or SQL or Hadoop or tableau. So,
these are the five things that we are trying to
extract as skills from a particular resume and we
are trying to see whether this particular resume
has any of these things or all of these things.
The next thing is phone number. So, what
we are trying to do is we are trying to
create projects, that projects should be able to
capture phone number and this phone number rejects
has been extracted from this StackOverflow
answer. So, I would like to give credit to that
answer that has created a regex that can handle
multiple different types of phone numbers. So,
we saw we want this a skill set. So we are
compiling this expression and then saving it
in skill set and this is the regex to capture
the phone number and then we are compiling it
and saving it in for now. And then what we are
trying to do is we are trying to take the text
that we just got inside this function and then we
are trying to do annotation. So if you remember
the basics of spacey video The first thing that
we have to do is annotation. Once that is done
what we are trying to do is we are trying to
extract two entities from the annotated the past
are the natural language processing text. So the
text on which the natural language processing has
been done on the text is nothing but the resume
content okay. So from the past content or from
the extracted text content, now we are trying to
do two things. The first thing is extract name.
The second thing is E So, totally we want four
components, which is name, email, phone number
and skill set. And we just saw creating regular
expressions for skill set and phone number.
And now we are trying to extract name and email id
and to start with the name what we are trying to
do is entity any named entity recognition has
one particular level which is called a person
that signifies the name of a person. So, what
we are trying to do is we are trying to do
if the entity label is person, then give me the
entity text and assign it in name. So, this in
Python is called a list comprehension, which
means, instead of writing a for loop in multiple
steps, you can write it in a single step. So, what
we are doing is we are doing a list comprehension
and then we are saying okay, whenever the
entity recognized entity, post label is person,
then give me that entity text. And then we are
saying okay, what if a resume has multiple names,
for example, first, the name of the person would
be on the top of the resume, probably their dad's
name and mom's name is there. So for that,
with that assumption that the person's name is
always on top of the resume, you're saying you
mean the first name that you detect. So we are
trying to take the first name that is detected
in the resume and then as any to name. Next,
we are also printing the name for us to have some
reference whose resume may have passed. Next is
we are trying to do email id extraction. So what
we are trying to do is we are trying to say okay,
for every word, the tokenized word in the
document. If the word is like email show
spacey has such an attribute, like underscore
email, if this word like underscore email,
which is returning a boolean value, either true
or false. If it is true, then give me the word.
And I'm telling, okay, give me the first word,
there will be multiple email ids. But I don't
care about the second and third email id, at least
for this particular project. So what I'm saying is
okay, give me the first email id and then store
it in email, and then print the email id again,
for a reference. Now that we have built the
regular expression for skill set and phone number,
it is time for us to use the expression
that we have compiled and then extract.
So there is one thing that we have to notice, we
are trying to convert the text enter text into
a lowercase before even proceeding further with
the regular expression. This is to solve the case
issue. So it could be like for example, let's say
this is Python, someone could have written Python
as capital P y to H and someone could have
written SQL as SQL capital or small letter
Java could be with J capital. So to solve this,
all these issues, we are normalizing all the texts
or downgrading all the text to a lower
case. And then we are saying okay,
rejects find all where you have phone number
pattern, and then the string on which you have
to find this text, which is what the argument that
we got. And then after converting into lowercase,
and then we are assigning the output to form after
converting it into a string object. So, simply
we have the text, we are converting into a
lower text, the text is the resume matrix,
we are converting everything into lowercase. And
then we are trying to find all everywhere in this
resume with this regular expression. And then
we are converting that result into a string and
then as entering into a foreign object. And then
the same thing that we are trying to do here is
find all the skill set text lower, and then assign
it to a skills underscore list because we will
have multiple skills one resume could have Python
and Java both. So that is why we are calling it as
skills underscore list. Also, one thing that
we have to notice in one particular resume,
we could have multiple instances of Python and
Java. For example, let us assume in the technical
skill section, someone has mentioned Python, but
also while describing the project, they might have
used the word Python. So what we would end up
getting here is in the skills underscore list,
we would end up getting Python two times
and we don't want to record Python two times
for that matter, because we want to see
whether Python is present or not present.
So, what we are trying to do is we are trying to
say okay, converted to a dictionary, which means
of course, it will have only unique
elements. And then we are converting
that into a string and then assigning it to
unique underscore skills underscore list. So,
in this entire section, we have defined the
regular expression for skill set and for number
we have used spacey for annotation and then we
have used the annotated text to extract a Persian
and then as Enter to name to see whether there
is anything like email then as Enter to email
and then we have used phone number and skill set
regular expression that we just compiled to find
everywhere where we have got and then we have got
the skills and unique skills. So right now, after
this, what we are trying to do is we are trying
to append these names in the placeholder list
that we just created. So these are the four empty
placeholder lists. recreated, so we are trying to
append all these that we just extracted in those
lists. And then finally, we are trying to print a
message or message to the user to say, extraction
has been completed successfully. So for a small
summary, this is the function, the core function
where we are extracting the four components,
it takes one argument, which is the text of
the resume. And then initially we are compiling
the regular expression for skill set and phone
number. Next, we are annotating the text document
using natural language processing of spacey,
and then we are extracting name, and then we
are extracting email, and then we are extracting
phone number and then we are extracting skills,
and then making unique skills out of it.
And then we are appending all those values
in the placeholder list that we created in the
previous cell. And then finally printing our user
message to say extraction has been completed.
So let us execute this thing and it has been
successfully executed. In the next line, what we
are trying to do is we are trying to say okay,
now I've got two main functions, one to convert
all the PDF to text. And also, you know,
meanwhile, save that txt file in the particular
folder. Second, use the text content and extract
whatever I wanted the four components name,
phone number, email id skills. And with this set,
now what I have to do is, I have to make this
project work on multiple files rather than
only one PDF file. So that center objective of
doing an automated bulk resume a parser, right,
so you don't really want to use a code just to
pass one Li one resume because a human being Of
course, could be better in passing one resume,
but assume that you are a manager and then you
have got 100 resumes or 200 resumes or 50 resumes.
And this is the case, we want to have an automated
resume a parser bulk resume a parser and that
is exactly what we are trying to do here. So
what we are trying to do here is we are trying to
list down all the files inside the folder resume.
As we just saw, we have three files.
Inside resume, we have three resume files,
and then we are saying okay, lists down all the
files and iterate through each of the file calling
it has file. So we will take individual resumes,
and we are calling it file. And then we are trying
to just validate whether the file name ends with
dot PDF. So in the same folder, you could have,
let's say, forgotten to convert a docx file into
PDF. So what we are trying to do is we are trying
to add an extra layer of validation to say, Okay,
I want only PDF, because right now this code is
built only to function with PDF. And if you have
got a docx, you have to manually convert a docx
to a PDF or you can find a lot of script online to
convert docx to PDF. So we are saying okay, if the
file name ends with the dot PDF, then first print
the user message that we are reading the file
and then read the file. Convert underscore PDF
is the function that the function that we just
created, invoking that and then the path where we
have all the files is this one. So the first file,
the first iteration, it will be the name of the
first file. In the second iteration, it will
be the name of the second file. And in the third
iteration, it will be the name of the third file.
And as we saw in this convert underscore PDF,
we are returning a file object, we opened the
file using the path and also we read it. So we
are assigning that output inside this object
called txt. And then now we are passing this txt
to the function that we just built here. So this
takes one text object as argument. So we are
passing that as the parameter here saying okay,
parse underscore content. txt, once we run this,
okay, first resume is read. Allison Parker's
resume is read. And then the output is saved
successfully. Allison Packers, right is the name,
email id. So these are all hypothetical names
that do not exist. So it's a disclaimer that
this is these are all hypothetical resumes, and do
not reflect to any living human being. So this is
the first resume PDF is red text to successfully
saved the exact same message that we printed here.
And then we have the name, which we also printed
here. And then we print the email ad, which is
here. And then we finally say extraction has been
successful. So this is first resume. Then this is
second resume, reading john domnick. saving it
as txt name, email id extraction completed. And
then finally, actually miles reading, saving it as
text extracting name, email ID, which is what we
printed, we didn't print phone number and skills
and then extraction complete successfully. So now
that we know that we have got three resumes, all
those three resumes have been successfully read,
what we are going to do is we are going to use
these placeholder values which is now populated
with all those names. So to give you some
perspective, names will have all the names phone
We'll have all the phone numbers, skills, we'll
have all the skills. And then of course, emails,
we'll have all the emails. Now that we have got
all the values of this placeholders populated. Now
we are going to say okay, assign these into these.
So this is a dictionary with it is a key value
pair, and this is the key and then we are going
to put this against the respective key as values.
So what we are doing here is we are saying,
okay, the value of this key should be names,
the value of key, this key should be phones. and
the value of this key email key should be emails.
And then finally skills, then to see how does it
look, let us execute this, then say result. And
that's good, which is the result dictionary. So
as you can see, the starts with a curly brace ends
with the curly brace, this is the key, and this is
all the values, this is the key, this is all the
values. So this is how a typical dictionary
in Python will look like. And then finally,
we have to convert into a tabular format, which we
will do using pandas DataFrame. So in this video,
we saw how to start with importing libraries
define two important functions. One is converting
PDF to text. The second one is the code the
main function, the it's like the engine of the
entire project, which is parsing the content and
extracting required components. And then finally
storing the required components into a Python
dictionary, which in the next video, we'll see how
to convert into a tabular format using pandas, and
also to save that CSV as an Excel file CSV file.
In this video, we'll see how to convert the
dictionary that we created into a tabular format
using pandas. And we will also see how to then
finally save this entire thing as a script to run
on a bulk, you know, set of files in a particular
folder. So to start with, this is where we left in
the previous video where we had created a result
underscore dict, which is a dictionary Python
dictionary, with all the essential content that we
just extracted from the three resumes that we had
got in the race image folder. So to move ahead
with, we are going to use pandas, which we just
imported at the start import pandas as PD is what
we used. pd is an alias. So we are going to use
that alias PD dot data frame. So the beauty of
pandas is that panda's data frame is nothing but
a Python dictionary internally. So it is easier
for us to convert result underscore date into a
data frame just by invoking this function called
Data Frame. From this lspd pd dot data frame.
We're framus the SS capital D and therefore
capital and pass result underscore dict
as any to result underscore df df stands for
data frame or you can give any name that you
would like to and then I'm printing df, which says
okay, this is my name. This is my phone number.
This is my email. And these are the skills that
I've got. So Alison has got it on Tableau and
Java. JOHN Dominic has got How do Python and Java
actually Myles has got SQL and tableau. And then
the next step is for us to save this entire thing
into a CSV file. As we saw in the previous video,
the folder structure that we've got, where
output has two folders subfolders. One is text,
which stores all the text files that are
converted from PDF, and in the CSV where
we have got the output CSV, we are going
to say okay, save the output CSV there.
And then we can go ahead and open the folder
and see that the output CSV is present here.
So until now, what we have seen is take the
dictionary convert into a tabular format,
which is a panda's data frame, and then
save that data frame into a CSV file.
But this Jupyter Notebook is good for us to
prototype. But now, the objective is, we have
a folder full of resumes. And then you know,
you want to give this to someone who cannot use
proper Python coding, and then they should be
able to convert all those PDFs into structured
content. And for that purpose, we are going
to convert this Jupyter Notebook into a Python
script and then use the Python script to convert
all those PDFs into text. So let us go ahead
and then open file, and then go to download as and
then do.py. This will give us the Python script.
But before we do that, we have to remove
those instances that are not required.
For example, we have a lot of places where
we have printed these things, which is
quite unnecessary. So we'll delete these cells.
You can use x To delete a cell, or probably
you can go here and then try and delete cell. So
I'll use x, delete, delete, delete, delete. Cool,
and then I'm going to Delete this dictionary. So
we are done with this as of now, and we can save
and checkpointed just for our reference,
then what we can do further is we can go
download Python read poi, so we'll save the file,
and then make sure that you have got the file
inside the folder, the current project folder. So
bring that file here, the current project folder,
where we have got all the files. So now,
you should have the folders that we defined
with the resume is with the input files, that
resume is with all the PDF regimens that we want
to be parsed. And then the output folder
with two subfolders, CSV and txt. txt.
And then also, the PDF to txt dot
p y should be inside this folder.
And this is the notebook that we just created
to create this entire project. And then finally,
the Python script of this Jupyter Notebook.
With this, we are good to go that we have got
resume underscore passing with this script will
use this script on command level as a CLA tool
to automate this entire process of converting PDFs
into a structured format of valuable content. But
before we do that, let us go ahead and then delete
these things because these were created when we
ran this particular code in the Jupyter Notebook.
But to make sure that the project is successful,
we'll delete this. And also we'll delete
the output file, we have got an output file,
we'll delete this output file also. So right now,
let us just validate, we have got three resumes,
Alison Parker, Ashley Mays, Dominic, john Dominic.
And in fact, you can notice that this is all three
different formats. This is a double column, this
is a single page resume. So we have got different
resume formats. And then output does not have
anything, output is empty with two subfolders,
empty subfolders. And then we are all set to test
our script on this the resumes folder. To see
the code that we just have created using the
Jupyter Notebook the Python script that we just
downloaded from the Jupyter Notebook, it could
be used for automation, so open the terminal. Or
if you are using Windows, please open your command
prompt. And then make sure that you are inside the
project folder. So my project folder name is
resuming parsing, I can use LS to check Okay,
or if you are using Windows, check the command
to see where you have got your current folder. So
you can see that this is my current folder. And
then it shows that I've got this file regime
underscore parsing in place. They've also got the
folders like output resumes, and the main PDF to
txt dot p file. So with this, what we can do is
we can say resume a underscore parsing dot p y
but before we do that, we have to say Python
three phase resume underscore parsing.py. So the
same name that we have given here to say Python
three ratio parsing that py. Once you press enter,
we'll see all the details that we have done. So
for example, this is exactly what we saw. First
reading Allison Parker's the first resume output
is txt saved name, email extraction completed
second resume at john Dominic, john Dominic
txt saved name email id successfully completed
and then the third resume actually miles CSV
reading PDF saving txt name email ad successfully
completed now we can see okay LS nothing has
changed. Let us enter into resumes folder.
And then we will see okay, LS we can see that
there are three files which is what we used as
input. Now let us come out you see the space dot
dot coming out and then doing LS just to validate
where we are and then let us get into output. And
then you can see LS, we have two folders, CD txt
and then LS we can see that we have got three txt
files. So initially before we started with this
execution of the script, we did not have these
txt files. Now we have this txt file which means
the conversion of PDF to txt has been successful.
Now let us also validate whether we have got the
structured information in the form of CSV. So let
us go out cd space dot.we are again inside output.
We'll get into CSV and then say okay,
we have got the CSV inside CSV, LS.
We have got parsed underscore resumes dot
CSV, which means the script that we executed
has completely done what we did with the
notebook which means the script is perfect,
that the automation is successful, that it picks
all the resumes folder resume. And it converts
everything into txt and saves inside txt. And then
it also finally creates one CSV file, which is
the parsed resumes file. So now let us go ahead
and go to output, open CSV now that we find CSV
in this folder, let us right click it and open
the CSV with Microsoft Excel for us to see, okay,
this is Excel, the CSV has been opened, you
can see that okay name is their phone number,
their email it is their skill is there? And
how can you use the output of this project? Let
us assume that you are HR manager or you are the
recruiting manager, and you want to use the output
of this project and you have got, let's say maybe
100 names like that. The way you can use it is,
right now you have a requirement for a SQL
Developer, SQL Developer, what can you do?
You can just go there, apply this filter and say,
Okay, I want someone with SQL. What do you get?
Let's say you go to the header, let us format
this header a little bit. And then you go to
the header, and then say filter, and I
want someone with SQL, then you see Oh,
you've got Ashley miles with SQL skillset. And
additionally, Ashley miles also has tableau.
So maybe let us pick up Ashley, my email ad and
then male and ask if he would be interested in
joining our company for an interview or let us
assume that you have another requirement where
you want someone with Tableau and then in this
case, you will go put a filter and say one blue,
then you see okay, Alison Parker right. And Ashley
Mize has Tableau skill set. And then you know,
now let us prioritize that these two resumes for
interview and then go ahead and then call them for
interview. So this is the main objective of this
project. So if you have got a lot of resumes, like
50 resumes, it is nearly impossible for one human
being to literally go through all the resumes.
But using an automated script, a bulk resume a
parser that we have built using this project,
what we can do is we can extract the essential
skill set that we want. And as you know, you can
change the skill set like you wanted in the regex
expression that we built, and then filter it using
Excel to say, Okay, these are the resumes that I'm
going to focus instead of just going randomly with
all the 50 resumes. So in this section, we learned
how to build an automated bulk resume parser
using natural language processing and regular
expression. We also alongside learned basics
of regular expression and how to implement it in
Python. And we also saw introduction to spacey,
and natural language processing using spacey.
And then once we successfully built the script
to completely convert a resume a which
is in PDF and an unstructured format into
a structured tabular format. We saved it
in CSV and we saw how we can use that CSV
to prioritize resumes for selecting the
right resume for the job requirement.
Thank you for watching this video,
and we'll see the next section.
In this section, we'll learn how to build an image
typeconverter. Converting images from one image
type to another image type like PNG to JPG JPG
to PNG, or BMP to PNG is one of the most wanted
tools that every one of us expect to have handy.
To build such a tool, we'll start learning with
basic image manipulation in Python, then we'll
understand what are the Python packages used for
image manipulation. And then finally, we'll build
a tool that helps us do image type conversion.
The section contains following topics, what are
the different types of an image what is an image
type converter, Introduction to image manipulation
in Python, and the Python packages used further.
And then finally, we'll build a script project
that will help us do image type conversion. In
the next video, we'll learn what are the different
types of image file formats, and its details.
In this video, we'll learn what are the different
type of image file formats, and its details. image
file formats are standardized means of organizing
and storing digital images. The image file
format is usually identified by the image file
format extension that comes with the file name,
and image file format is required to store data
in an uncompressed or compressed or vector format.
Once rasterized, an image becomes a grid of
pixels, each of which has a number of bits to
designate its color equal to the color depth of
the device displaying it. In general, an image
file format defines how data is stored the image
data is stored in that particular file format. And
image compression can be of two types. lossless
compression The other one is a lossy compression.
In a lossless compression the image and file
format is change the compression is usually
lossless, which means there is no information loss
in a lossy compression. The algorithm preserves a
representation of the original uncompressed image
that may appear to be a perfect copy but it is not
so often lossy compression able to achieve
smaller file sizes than lossless compression
and it is highly preferred when you're going to
transfer image from one place to another place
where you need to compress the image. What are
the various different types of image file format,
the most widely used and in internet the file
format that has been highly preferred to be
used for Image Transfer is JPEG. jpg stands
for joint photographic experts group,
which is a lossy compression which means JPEG
is a compression algorithm that stores image
data in a compressed format. After JPEG on of the
highly preferred file format is PNG. png stands
for Portable Network graphics file format. png was
originally created as an alternative for GIF, or
GIF, however you want to share it give stands for
graphics Interchange Format. In the next video,
we'll see what are the different Python packages
that we'll be using in this particular project.
In this video will learn about the different
types of Python packages that we will be
using in this particular project. For image
manipulation, we are going to use a package called
PPI L stands for Python imaging library. Python
imaging library is one of the most popular Python
package which is free for image manipulation
in Python. However, there was no recent
support from ti l for any Python version that is
greater than three, which means PL supports only
Python version that is lesser than 2.7. So for
this, someone has formed a friendly fork of PL
repository, and that is called pillow pillow now
supports any new latest Python version that is
greater than three below was created by Alex Clark
and its contributors to pillow is the library for
image manipulation that we are going to use in
this particular project below follows the same
syntax as PL you have to make sure in a computer
where you have installed below that you do not
have bi l below can be installed using PIP which
we'll see later on. The next package that we are
going to use in this project is globe. globe is
simply for Unix style path manipulation. So to
identify the files images in our current folder,
we are going to use globe. So we are going to use
Glo to identify the current image files that is
in our current directory. And then we are going
to use pillow for converting into from one
format to another format. In the next video,
we'll learn how to install the required Python
packages and loading them into a project.
In this video, we'll learn how to install the
required Python packages and loading them into
our project. As we discussed earlier, the back
end that we are going to use is called below. So
let us open our terminal. If you are going to use
Mac, open your terminal. Or if you're going to use
Windows, open your command prompt. And make sure
that in your computer, if you have Python three,
you're going to use PIP three. So if you're going
to have Python three, use PIP three or if you're
going to have fight them less than 3.0 use PIP
so in my computer, I've got python 3.7. So I'm
going to use PIP three, install and below. Make
sure that your pee in pillow isn't capital letter
and then press enter the installation procedure
will start now. So right now, you can see that
below has been installed successfully for
you to verify a pillow has been installed
successfully. You can open Python console here
using Python three and then import pillow.
The reason that pillow is not found here is
because we also saw that pillow follows the
same syntax as pa l but it is just a simple folk.
But in this case, if you are going to use pillow,
you have to just simply input bi l make
sure that you have only one version of
pillow installed in your machine so that
there is no clash among the packages.
This is the only package that was required for
us to install. The other package that we saw
below is already available which also we can
verify by using import glow. It has been imported,
which means the package is available already by
default in python 3.0. In the next video, we'll
start with the coding part of creating our image
typeconverter script in this video We'll learn how
to code or image type converter script to begin
with, open your PI charm or any other Python ID
that you are going to use for this particular
project. Once you open your ID or pi charm in
my particular case, go to File and click New to
create a new Python file. Once you click New,
you'll get all these options and select Python
file to create a new Python file, you might have
to name the file upfront. So give a meaningful
name like image conversion new.pi. For ease of
process, I've already created the code and I'll
take you through section by section. The first
section we are going to load the library that
we are going to use in this particular project.
As we discussed earlier, you under the package
name that we are going to use is called pillow,
because it is a fork of p i e l library. So we
are going to use p L. So from PL we want to import
the class object image. And then we are going to
import blob, which is to identify the files with
a particular extension. So in this step, we are
going to use print globe dot globe. And we are
going to use this small regular expression pattern
that tells us that anything that starts with
anything, and then followed by a dot, and
then finally ends with a PNG, which means
we are going to tell Python that please give me
the list of files that have an extension PNG.
To understand this, let us see the current working
directory of the current working directory offers.
We have three PNG files. As you can see, the first
one is Batman logo. The second one is Powerpuff
Girls, and the third one is Tom and Jerry dot
png. So all these PNG files will be displayed.
Once we run this code. The next section, we
are going to iterate through the PNG files,
each and every file. And then we are going to open
the image file and then assign it to a new Python
variable called iron. Once we assign it to the new
Python variable called Iam, we are going to use
this is to apply a method called convert where
we are converting into tune to its RGB file
format. Our GB stands for red, green, blue, which
forms the complete color that we usually see.
So in this step, we're going to convert
the image that we read, which is a PNG
image after getting assigned into a new object,
we're going to convert it into its RGB format.
Please note that image conversion can also
have RGB, but RGBA is not something that
we are going to use here for that purpose
because JPEG is a file format that cannot
retain transparency. A stands for alpha alpha
represents transparency. So for a JPEG image,
it has only three properties, which is
our G B. But for a PNG image, for example,
if you're going to convert from a JPG to PNG
image, you need to have RGB A, which will convert
the image into a new file format along with this
attribute alpha, which stands for transparency,
which is not required for our current use
case. So we will use RGB format and convert
the input image. And then finally, while saving
the image, we are going to use the same file name,
which is what we read. And then we are just going
to replace the extension from PNG to jpg. And then
it also gives us the flexibility of setting the
quality value depending upon how large the images.
So if you want the image to be more compressed low
quality, if you want to upload it online, then you
can reduce the quality which means the size of
the image will also be reduced. Because we have
given it in a for loop, it is going to happen for
all the files that we have got. So let us go ahead
and run the code. So to run the code, we can go
here and pi charm and then just execute the code.
As you can see, the code has completely executed
and then it has displayed all the PNG that we had.
And then it also has finished with exit code
zero. As you might have noticed, initially,
when we had opened this finder, the Explorer where
we had all the files, we had only PNG file format,
but you can see now that we have also created
new JPG file format. And to notice the difference
when you open Batman Lego file you can actually
see that there is no background in there,
which means it is completely transparent, which
is one of the attributes of a PNG image. But when
you actually see the JPEG image, which is this
one, you actually see that the entire background
has been filled with the black color. That is what
happens when we had done this conversion where the
attribute alpha has been lost. So in this project,
we learned how to import the Python image library,
how to find PNG in the current working directory,
and then how to convert this image from one file
format to another file format with different
quality level outcomes. impression level. In the
next video, we'll learn how to execute our Python
project that we just created using the terminal.
In this video, we'll learn how to execute a Python
project using terminal or Command Prompt. What we
did in the previous project has been imported
below package. And then we iterated through all
the PNG files in our current directory. And then
we converted all those PNG files into a JPEG.
But the problem with that in sharing the code
is that someone has to have the knowledge of
Python to open the text editor, or to open pi
charm and then run the code. To avoid that,
we can convert this enter code into a Python
executable file, which is something that we have
already created in the previous project. So the.py
file that we had created in the previous project
is what we are going to use in our terminal
or bash, or shell, a Windows command prompt,
and then use that py file to execute and then
convert everything within our shell itself. So
this way, we can convert the entire project into a
single click command line utility. So let us first
get into our current working directory where we
have got all the files under code. In my case,
image type conversion is where I've got
image underscore conversion is where
I've got my code, and then project file to check
that we can use their Linux command ls to see what
are all the files in our current directory.
So as you can see, we have three PNG files,
and we have the Python file that we had created
in the previous project. So to execute this file,
let us first copy this file name, right click
Copy. And once the file name is copied, remember
whether you have got Python, or just Python three,
which means if you have got Python less than 3.0,
you have to use this command Python. Or if you
have to, if you have Python version greater
than 3.0, you have to use Python three. So in my
case, I've got Python version 3.0. So I'm going
to use Python three here as the first command. And
then I'm going to put my file name which is image
underscore conversion dot p y. This command is
going to execute image underscore conversion.py,
which will iterate through these PNG files and
create new JPEG files. So let us see. So as we
have executed, in just a microsecond, this nta
code has got executed. And then we can see that
the pipe PNG files have got listed, and then
the code is completely successfully executed.
Now let us see whether the new files are there
available in the current working directory.
So to check that we can use the same command ls,
and then see, as you can see, we have new files,
which has this extension called JPG and JPEG and
jpg. So let us go to the folder where we have got
all these files. As you can see, initially, we
had only PNG files. And after this execution,
we have all these JPG files. To just verify this,
once again, we'll delete all these JPG files.
And then we'll go back and then check using
a list. Yes, there is no JPG files in this
current directory. And then we'll run the same
command again, to execute the image conversion
Python file. I'm going to use Python three
because my Python version is greater than 2.7.
So once we executed this, we can go to the current
working directory, and then see that we have got
new JPG files. And as we see last time, this
Batman Lego has got no background, which is one
of the properties of PNG files we saw but alpha
and the JPEG version of the same Batman Lego has
got a black color background, which means the JPG
file has replaced the transparent background with
a black color. So this project, we learned how to
create an image type converter using Python using
the library pi L, which stands for Python image
library. And then we converted that code into a
shell script where we can execute in one line that
the entire conversion will happen for all the PNG
files in our current working directory. Thank
you for listening. See you in the next section.
In this section, we'll learn how to build an
automated new summarizer. The reason we call it
an automated new summary is because the machine
learning algorithm is doing the summarization
technique for us with no manual effort of going
through the long text of news. News summarization
is nothing but the text summarization of news.
We'll start seeing an introduction to text
summarizer and its techniques. we'll implement
one such text summarization procedure and Python.
With that, we would have extracted this summarise
text of the news and thus we would have got our
automated news summaries are in place. Let us
go ahead and start seeing the course section.
In this video we will learn about take
summarization. Take summarization is the process
of extracting meaningful text that is shorter
in length from a huge chunk of larger text.
Using algorithms powered by natural
language processing and machine learning.
Take summarization is actually one of the most
exciting fields in machine learning and natural
language processing, which is NLP. Automated text
summarization allows engineers and data scientists
to create software's and tools that can
quickly find and extract keywords and phrases
from documents thus creating a summarized takes
take summarizes are implemented in a variety of
web applications and mobile applications
to deliver summarized content, or news.
And the example is there is an app in short, which
is one of the most popular news apps in India
that delivers a summarized text from a larger
use. Take summarization usually are of two types,
the technique is of two types. The first
one is extraction. And then the second
one is abstraction. The extraction technique, the
automated system or algorithm that we have built,
extracts objects from the entire collection of
text without modifying the objects, which means
it extracts key phrases from the entire text that
we have given and then ranks those sentences based
on its importance. And then finally gives a text
summarized format of text using only those most
important sentences. So in this case, there is no
modification of objects that are present inside
the actual text that has been provided. The second
technique is abstraction, under abstraction,
instead of just merely copying the information
from the given text. What it does is it
actually pair up phrases the entire section. So
it takes the entire text, paraphrases the section,
and then finally identify key words and then key
phrases, and then uses natural language processing
to create a new text which is more meaningful,
and also covers the context. And then finally,
it uses the summarized text of the original text
that is given. So there are two techniques. The
first one is extraction, which actually returns
the entire document without modifying the objects
but a minimalistic version of using only important
sentences. The second one is it breaks down the
entire sentence, multiple objects, and then it
builds meaningful sentences using natural language
processing by paraphrasing the sections, and then
we get the summarize text. In the next video,
we'll learn about what kind of technique we
are going to use in this particular project,
what Python package we are going to use for that
purpose, and how to install that Python package to
proceed further. Thank you. In the previous video,
we learned a bit about text summarization. In this
video, we will see what kind of text summarization
Are we going to use, and then the Python library
required for that. So text summarization is
of two types. As we saw in the previous video,
one is extraction. The second one is abstraction.
So in this particular project, we'll use
extraction method for text summarization. And the
Python package that we are going to use is called
Jensen. So the Jensen implementation of text
summarization is based on a popular algorithm
called text rank. Text rank algorithm is a
graph based ranking model for text processing.
An important aspect of text rank is that it
does not require deep linguistic knowledge,
which means text rank model is highly portable
to any other domain or language. Which means if
you have built a model using English language,
you can use the same algorithm for a different
language without any further major changes. Jensen
is also known as topic modeling in Python gensim
is a pythonic library for topic modeling, document
indexing and similarity retrieval for large text
corpora. The target audience for Jensen is the
one who uses natural language processing and
information retrieval or information extraction.
gensim is particularly one of the most popular
Python libraries especially for topic modeling.
gensim is been open sourced by a company called
Ray technologist or a ray technologists, let us
see how to install gensim on our computer, open
your terminal or if you're using Windows, open
your command prompt. And then type crypt three as
we have seen before, if you're using Python
three, you need to type PIP three install
if you already have got gensim so use for
upgrade Jensen, once you type this on enter
gensim would start getting downloaded on your
machine as Jensen is related to topic modeling and
then much more. There are many pre trained models
that comes with gentlemen language models also.
So for that purpose gensim is quite heavy and it
will take some time to get installed. So as we can
see gensim has got installed successfully. So let
us clear that up. mil and open our Python console
to see if Jensen has been successfully installed.
So import gensim Yeah, as you can see gensim
has been successfully installed without any
error. So we can now exit Jensen. So Jensen
is the library that we are going to use for text
summarization, automatic summarization. But for
us to get the text itself because we are going to
do new summarization, we need to extract the text
from news which means the news is published on
internet and we need to extract text from news
and to extract text from news we are going to use
something called a beautiful so as we have seen in
the previous sections beautifulsoup is the library
that we are going to use for extracting text from
internet. As we can see, it could be from HTML or
XML. So Beautiful Soup is the library that we are
going to use for web scraping, which is to extract
text from internet to install beautifulsoup we
need to type pip install Beautiful Soup for so
let us once again open our terminal or shell
and clear the text that we have gotten there and
then installed beautiful so PIP three install
Beautiful Soup work because it is the latest
version of Beautiful Soup. So we have to type
Beautiful Soup for so as you can see here the
terminal that I have already got Beautiful Soup
installed in the previous section. So my Beautiful
Soup requirement has been already satisfied.
If you have not got beautiful soup, Beautiful Soup
would get freshly installed on your machine. Let
us open our Python console. And then try to
see if we have got Beautiful Soup installed.
So let us save from bs for import Beautiful
Soup, which is the object of our interest. So
as you can see beautifulsoup the object from the
package beautiful. So for it's been successfully
imported. So remember this always when we
install Beautiful Soup, it should be installed
as Beautiful Soup for all and small critters.
But when you are importing Beautiful Soup,
it is from this package bs four and then you input
the object beautiful. So let us exhibit evil soup.
So in this video, we learned a little bit about
the kind of text summarization technique that we
are going to use in this project. The package name
Jensen that we are going to use in this project,
how to install Jensen, and then a little bit
about Jensen and we also saw that we need
beautifulsoup the Python package beautifulsoup
for web scraping, which is to extract
text from the web, you are the news
that we are going to be of our interest.
In the next video, we'll learn how to extract the
news text from the internet using beautifulsoup.
In this video, we'll see how to use Beautiful
Soup the Python package Beautiful Soup
to extract text from the internet news source.
So to begin with, let us import the packages
that we want for text extraction. The first one
is beautiful. So as we know before Beautiful Soup
is a web scraping library that we are going
to use to extract text from a new source. The
second package that we are going to use is called
request. The request package is used to extract a
web content Beautiful Soup is used to parse the
text content that we extracted using a request
package. So after we import the packages from bs
four input Beautiful Soup from request input gate,
so the reason why we are importing a particular
object or a function from a package instead of
loading the entire package is because memory
management if we have got a huge package like
Jensen, and if we import the entire package, then
the primary memory will be occupied with a huge
memory chunk of this particular package. So it
is always better to import only the packages
only the functions only the objects that are our
interest rather than importing the entire package.
So likewise, Beautiful Soup object is of our
interest and in the function request that we
wanted from the request package. So once we do
that thing, let us create a custom function. The
purpose of this function is to extract one Li the
text component, so extract only the text component
from paragraph text. So in a typical website, a
web URL you will see text spread across different
tags. It could be in a span tag, it could be in
a h1 tag h2 tag h3 tag, or it could be in a div,
it could be anywhere. So the tag that is of our
interest is paragraph tag, which is a HTML tag
which is denoted by this symbol P. So what we are
going to do is we are going to create a custom
function. The first step in the function is the
function is reading the URL. So the function is
trying to get a sense HTTP request to get the URL
using request package and then it stores it in
page. Once it stores it in page we are going
to use beautifulsoup to parse the content Using
a XML parser. So we are using l XML parser to
parse the content that we just extracted using the
get function and then we are storing it in soup.
So next step is we are going to identify why only
the paragraph text, and then we are going
to save it in text. The reason we are using
lambda function is to iterate these four different
tags. The reason is, because in a particular page,
there could be different paragraph text. So
we are using soup dot find all to find all
the paragraph text and then we are using lambda
function to iterate this page or text to all this
paragraph function that we found out. And then
we are finally using join to join all the text
and store it in a text object. The next thing is,
it is always good to present the title. So what
we are going to do is, apart from the text that we
extracted, we are going to extract the title also,
the reason we are using soup, low title, dots,
strings is because the title might sometimes
come with escape strings like slash in the denotes
end of line or slash tab that denotes a tab space.
So to strip out those strings, we are using soup
dot title dot strip strings. And then again, we
are using join to join all the words that we have
got and then store it in title. And then finally,
we are returning this as title comma text,
which will be read as a tupple. So finally,
we are sending it as a tupple. And then the
custom function that we wanted to create is done,
the function name is get underscore onely
underscore txt, and then the argument that we
are passing is the URL that we want to extract
the text from. So once this function is done,
let us execute this. And then the next step is the
news URL from which we are going to extract the
text. This is the URL from where we are extracting
the News, the news is from a very popular media
publishing site called works. The news title is
California is cracking down on the gig economy.
And then this is what we are going to
use to extract and summarize text from
once we take this URL, and then we put this URL
within the function that we just created. So
you can see, the function that we created is
called get underscore only underscore text.
And then we are passing this URL as a character or
string, the string argument is passed on to this
URL. And let us execute this URL. As you can see,
it just finished executing. And let us print the
text object to see if it has successfully scraped
extracted the text. So you can see that the text
is available now. And let us just see how large
this text is. In other words, how many number of
words we have got. So once we execute this thing,
the way we find it out is we take the string,
and then we split the strings using str dot
split as words and then we are using the length
of the words to see how many words we have got. So
you might doubt Why have I used text one instead
of just text. So as we created the function before
I mentioned that we are returning it as a tupple.
A tupple is a different type of Python object
from a list. So a tupple is an immutable
object. So the reason we have returned it as
a tupple is because we wanted to return title
and takes in the same expression. So that is
why we have returned both. So if you see text
length of text, it will show you two which means
it is a tupple with two objects in it. So you can
also see it opens with an open bracket and it ends
with a close bracket as opposed to a list which
would open with a square bracket and close with
the square bracket. And that is the reason why
we are excluding this because text of zero would
be the title and text of one is the actual text
that we want. So text of zero would be the title
and the text of one is what we actually wanted.
And that is why we are using text of one to use
string split and then split it by words and then
calculate the number of words entered. So in
this video, we learned how to use beautifulsoup
and request to extract the text from the new
source. And we also saw what is the length of the
text the extracted text which is 1600 25. In
the next video, we will learn how to do text
summarization using Jensen. In this video, we'll
see how to do text summarization automated text
summarization of that extracted text
that we did it in the previous video.
So as a first step, we need to import all the
required Python packages. The Python package that
we are going to use here is Jensen as we know
before and within gensim. We are interested of
two functions one is summarize the second one is
keywords. So from Jensen, we are going to import
summarize and keywords. So Say do from Jensen dot
summarization towards summarizer import summarize,
and then from Jensen dot summarization import
keywords once you have typed this in execute
your Jupyter notebooks. So once this is
executed, your Python package has been
successfully imported. So the next step is for
us to do text summarization, text summarization,
as it might look very complicated gensim is
offering us this in a single function. So, how
we can do this is the first one is the function
called summarize, and then we have to pass the
text to this. So, the text that we have extracted
in the previous step as we saw as a tupple. So,
what we have to do is we have to do text dot
one, and then the summarize function as a first
argument it takes text the actual text content
as a second argument it actually takes ratio.
And then the third argument is word count. The
thing with this is it can be either done with
ratio or with the word God not with both. So, if
you supply both with means ratio, let us say ratio
is equal to point 01. So, the ratio is nothing but
the ratio of text summarised text that you want,
as opposed to the original text. So, in text
summarization, we use summaries as a function,
we can either use ratio or word count as
argument to extract to limit the amount of text
that we wanted. So, let us start with the first
method, which we'll use using word count. So,
using summarize function, we are passing the text
which is of text one, and then we are using the
word count that I want us 100 which means I do not
want more than 100. So, in the previous video, we
saw that we have totally 1600 25 words, and then
we are going to extract only 100 words out of it,
which is meaningful as summarized text. So, to
make it a little bit, the cosmetic changes to
the output, we are going to say okay, this is
the title and then we are using text of zero
to print the title and then we are saying
this is somebody and then this embrace text.
Once we execute this thing, we see that we
have got the title of walks. And then we are
getting the summarized text which says okay,
the State Assembly has passed a bill which
makes it harder for companies to label worker as
an independent contractor instead of employees,
which is what usually happens in gig economy.
So, as a first step, we have extracted our text
and the number of words that we have got is let us
say, is 98. So we limited our word count to 100.
And then we have got 98 words. So this is the
first method where we have extracted the text
using word count as an argument to put a
threshold. In the second method, what we are
going to do is we are going to say I do not want
to put a threshold of word count, what I want is
I'm giving a ratio, the ratio can be anything
between zero and one. And then within this,
it will use as an approximation as the ratio of
the original text which is 1600 25. And then given
this ratio, it will give us how much text that we
are going to be given. So what we are going to do
is we are going to use the same function, text
off one because we just wanted the text and then
we are going to say ratio of point one and then
see how much are we getting. So you can see that
you've got the title, and then you've got the
text. If you want to reduce this text further,
we can say instead of point 01, we can say point
zero, let's say 7.07, which further reduces their
takes. If you are interested in reading more
text instead of point 01, we can say point
two which is giving us more text point one giving
us less text. So as you can see that we have
extracted the summary using a different
method other than specifying the word count.
But still it is good for us to see how much it
has reduced. So what we'll do is we'll copy this
function, which is where we have got the output
text. And then we'll say we are going to put it as
summarized. Text is equal to this is an we'll
execute this once we execute this, we have got
the summary sticks. Now, we are going to use the
summarize text and then put it inside our text
length function to see how many words we have
got we have got 217 words. In the previous
muttered we got 98 words because we had set a
threshold using the word count. In this method,
we have set a threshold using the ratio and then
we have got 217 words. So this is how we have
extracted summaries text, but sometimes not just
summarize text is enough but you also want to see
the keywords that are more important that the
algorithm has found out. So what we are going
to do in this step is we are going to extract
the keywords that is of more importance. And
we are going to use the same method. So, we are
going to say keywords, which is the function name
for the first argument is the text that we are
passing the original takes. The second argument
is we are setting a threshold using the ratio. And
then the third argument says whether you want to
do lemmatization or not. So, to understand what is
lemmatization So, let us first exude this function
without lemmatization function. So, once you
exude this thing you might see okay the critical
keywords are drivers, code codes, workers,
worker states state contractors contractor
So, even though it gives us keywords,
sometimes you might see the reputation
one has quote unquote, state and states
contractors and contract This is because we have
not done lemmatization lemmatization is a process
of taking a word and then converting it to a root
word. For example, workers would be converted
into worker coats would be converted into code
contractors would be converted into contractor
which means we would not see duplication because
of that just one extra word. So, let us go ahead
and then do lemmatization Lemma ties through,
it's a Boolean flag. Once we execute this thing,
now, we have got the new set of keywords, which is
just quotes Ober, contractor, business worker,
and there is no plural form and singular form
because we have done lemmatization we can do this
for that other method also. So in this video, we
have learned how to successfully do automated text
summarization using the Jensen function summarize
and also we learned how to do it using two
different methods. One is using ratio, the second
one is using word count. Apart from this, we also
learned how to do Tech's keyword extraction. So
one is text summarization. The next one is keyword
extraction. To find out more relevant or important
keywords, for example, if you are going to run a
Google AdWords campaign for this particular text,
then you need to understand what are the keywords
critical keywords that are presented in this
particular word, text, and then we'll run the
campaign we'll do the bidding accordingly.
So in the next video, we'll learn how to make this
a complete project and then we'll see a summary.
In this video, we'll see how you can take
this further forward. So, as you can see,
what we have done is we have used a Jupyter
Notebook to create this particular project.
So Jupyter Notebook is good if we want to
incorporate text, which is narrative as markdown
and also the code and also the output. But Jupyter
Notebook is not applicable for every purpose.
So for example, let us take that you want to do
this project as an automation. So what you want
to do is you want to take a particular URL, and
then you want to shedule this in your computer
to get the summarized text from a news
source every day, let us say morning.
So in that case, what you can actually do
is you can go to your Jupyter Notebook file,
and then you can download this Jupyter Notebook
as a.py file. So instead of having it as a Jupyter
Notebook, you can download this as a.py file,
which means you are going to get a Python code.py
file, which you can use your Windows Task
Scheduler or Mac Automator, to schedule it
every day at a certain point of time. So this is
one thing that you can do this in this project.
The second thing, what you can do is, instead
of a Jupyter Notebook, you can use this Jupyter
Notebook to create a more generalized version of
this project. And then you can convert it as a
command line project. So where you can just
invoke this project with an argument of URL,
and then it will give you a summarized text.
So in this project in this URL, if you see,
we have hard coded the URL. But instead of hard
coding the URL, what you can actually do is
you can use this as an argument that could be
paused at the command level. And then what you
can do is you can use your terminal to invoke this
Python project, passing the desired URL in the
terminal as an argument and then you can extract
the text as an output. So there are two things
that you can do further with this project. One is
extracting the Python code and then scheduling it
so that you get the news into your inbox every
day. Or instead of that you can have it as a
Python project, the same.py file, but in a more
generalized format instead of hard coding the URL.
And then you can get the extracted summarized
text whenever you supply a URL to this particular
project. But if you do not wish to do any of
these things, you can just keep it as this Jupyter
Notebook. And then what you can do is whenever you
want to change the URL, you can give a different
URL here and then there under text and the text to
this algorithm, this notebook would give you the
desired output where you can use to read the news
of a summarized format. Like just like headlines
are how the in shorts app which we saw that
most popular news application in India would
be doing to send a card of text, which is a
very summarized version of the actual news.
In this video, we'll learn how to take this
project further. So far. In this section,
we learned how to build an automated new
summarizer. We started with understanding
what is the new summarizer and what kind of
techniques are available. And then we learned
about the Python packages required for it. And
then finally, we did new summarizer using Jensen
and the text extracted using beautifulsoup. I
hope you enjoyed the project. Thank you very much.